this video is brought to you by kamikoto
knives Dragon Ball Super's rumored
return is on the horizon but it's also a
show that's got a lot of criticism over
the years and not just for me from its
humble and troubled Beginnings in
development all the way to its somewhat
ill-conceived plot elements towards the
end it's no wonder Dragon Ball super has
made a name for itself as one of the
most controversial Dragon Ball
properties in circulation but I ask is
it as bad as people say or is it better
nowadays in light of the recent films
and manga Arc Super's fan base has grown
and gone from strength to strength and
seeing as I've shared my detailed and
comprehensive thoughts on both Dragon
Ball and GT respectively I think it's
only fair that I share my in-depth and
detailed thoughts on the show that
effectively kick-started this channel
everyone I hope you're ready because
here's my take on Akira toriyama's most
controversial Series this is my massive
review for Dragon Ball super
[Music]
all right so because this is a beefy boy
I figured like all the other massive
Dragon Ball Reviews I've done I'll break
this monster up into its clearly defined
story arcs Battle of Gods and
Resurrection F the two adapted films the
universe 6 tournament arc our first
Glimpse at new material in Super's anime
the Future Trunks or Goku black are
arguably the most popular Arc in the
series and finally the universe survival
Arc with the tournament of power the
series is Big finale sounds simple
enough right so let's dive into first
and foremost the most troubled arcs in
all of the series Battle of God's end
Resurrection f
having grown up with this series when it
was announced that the Dragon Ball anime
would finally be returning to our
screens with none other than Akira
Toriyama at the helm the excitement
within me was bubbling to the surface
like nothing else I'd get to see Goku
and all the guys again Count Me In but
it turned out that the first two arcs
are remix of the movie 's told through a
series instead of a film like they were
written to be I'm sure this won't have
any negative side effects at all so
let's kick things off Battle of Gods
episode 1. as First episodes go this
really is a mixed bag I distinctly
remember liking it back in the day and
while there are aspects to it that are
nice specifically Goku's interactions
with Goten Mr Satan at the end and maybe
some introductions to beerus the vast
majority of this episode is spent
avoiding the plot entirely it's like
they're trying to spend as much time as
they can reintroducing characters
without any real reason as to why like
there's literally a scene where Videl
gives Gohan a book and Piccolo is seen
staring at them from atop a roof like
why the most important thing Piccolo
does in this Arc is play Bingo but by
far the worst aspect of this particular
episode is the mini story that takes
place within it Trunks and Goten looking
for a birthday gift further down it
doesn't feel like a part of anything and
distinctly feels like a waste of time
and it's only episode one with that said
the ending to this episode I really
enjoyed the compositing and the color
used so it has that going for it episode
two this episode deals with Vegeta
mostly while the last episode featured a
lot of reintroductions to various
characters that don't add much to the
story the character of focus I thought
was Goku who began and ended that very
episode it served to provide reason and
context as to why Goku was training on
King Kai's Planet the place where we
find him at the beginning of Battle of
Gods and so providing a reason for him
to be there was a nice inclusion that
added to the story or at least enriched
it Goku receives money therefore he gets
to go to King Kai's because Chichi
allows him but this episode covers
Vegeta mostly and while admittedly cute
it doesn't provide for the character the
same setup it did for Goku in the
episode prior it's pretty much just him
chilling out with his family on vacation
nothing more before flying off in a huff
like you'd expect him to it does plop
him into the gravity chamber at the end
like he was at the beginning of the
battle of God's movie so at least
they're getting into place albeit in a
clunky Way episode 3. it's at this point
I realize I still know all the Japanese
lyrics to chozetsu Dynamic the first
theme song to Dragon Ball super
reminding me I've watched way too much
of this show in this episode beers way
back to his Homeworld with whis rambling
about the Super Saiyan God dream he had
the other night in addition to this the
festivities for bulma's party start
getting underway there's not really much
to report here other than it is an
entirely different location to that of
the battle of God's movie The Party
taking place on a cruise ship instead of
the briefs compound Goku on the other
hand is still on King Kai's Planet but
he's wearing this lovely jogging suit
while they do this really terrible run
animation for way way way too long this
is the first indication of something
serious to follow the animation in this
show is about to tank
and it only gets worse from here the
best part of this episode is during the
bathhouse scene with beerus when whis
introduces him to the man that defeated
Frieza much to beerus's surprise and we
see some nice reanimated scenes of Goku
and Frieza on Namek it's pretty neat
episode 4. I hate this episode I hate it
I hate it so so very much I'm not sure
if I hate it because I'm not a fan of
the characters the writing or the fact
that I know this entire episode is
largely a massive waste of time but I
assume it's a combination of the
aforementioned beerus is on his way to
King Kai's to confront Goku which is
fine but nothing to write home about
King Kai is stressing out and bulma's
party is happening all the while Trunks
and Goten check out the prizes for the
various games at his mom's party this is
when we catch up with the peel off gang
they are fishing for food the boat is
broken and they see bulma's ship passing
man what a coincidence they get chased
by a shark or something eat some food
and look for the Dragon Balls we do get
some training scenes with Vegeta and a
much less visually impressive Kamehameha
Recreation from the Battle of God's film
before beerus and whis are Drive
bringing the episode to a close episode
5. I can't begin to describe to you all
the joy that this episode makes me feel
but first a little history the funny
thing about this episode is that when it
aired the animation caused the world to
point the finger and laugh at the show I
mean it was awful entirely down to a
decision made by management to give the
show a super short pre-production window
and so after
they did to their credit but what they
didn't count on was that I would go out
of my way to preserve history and keep
the originally uncorrected episode that
aired in 2015 on my hard drive for years
waiting for this very day to come so
enjoy this uncorrected air date footage
this is the first action heavy episode
of the series 2 which for an action
Shonen isn't exactly a good sign the
entire episode deals with Goku's battle
with beers on his search for the Super
Saiyan God which needless to say doesn't
go too well for Goku cycling through
forms that resemble Super Saiyan 1 2 and
eventually three which to the episode's
credit has a nice kind of Animation in
that form towards the end my favorite
part of this fight however was this
Frame I love this drawing it's like a
freeze frame during one of those old
action movies where you pause at just
the right time to see their stunt double
or something only on this particular
occasion Goku's don't double grins with
those vacant and blinking eyes into your
so may he be immortalized forever the
episode ends proper as Vegeta is alerted
to Goku's defeat and beerus's impending
arrival episode 6. this episode is a bit
of fun but again I'm not the biggest fan
Vegeta kicks off the episode while
staring angrily in his hand before
eventually finding he's in the company
of beerus the Destroyer who is there
again to look for the Super Saiyan God
Vegeta enjoys a nice little flashback to
his childhood that involves beerus after
falling to the floor this sets up the
president for Vegeta to have a mental
block with fighting beerus the party
itself continues Vegeta stresses out
makes takoyaki which by the way are
delicious Goten and Trunks have a water
gun fight followed by yet more Vegeta
nervous breakdowns
the big action sequence in this episode
comes as Vegeta fights a giant squid and
beerus takes out Majin Buu over a
disagreement involving pudding main
point beerus is mad despite Vegeta's
best efforts so it's time to fight
episode 7. this is obviously another
fighting heavy episode Majin Buu Vegeta
Gotenks Piccolo Tien 18 and even Gohan
throw caution to the wind and given to
go clashing with the god of the beerus
himself is in a hurry to blow up the
planet and leave but we seems too
distracted by the sushi on offered right
as Vegeta is in the same position as his
father before him Bulma intervenes and
slaps Barris right in the face hold up I
think it's quite funny here that she of
all people is the first person to land a
blow on beerus however taken aback by
this beerus sends Bulma flying across
the deck with a single slap of his own
causing Vegeta to explode with anger
again this isn't nearly as visually
interesting as the film's version but
it's at the very least more interesting
than the rest of the episode and the
majority of this show so far episode 8.
I hate this episode the fight between
Barris and Vegeta is
average and not regular average Dragon
Ball super average and the firing of
that garlic gun always looks awful but
that fight isn't what makes me hate this
episode oh no it's that a large chunk of
it is spent watching the Antics that
surround a game of rock paper scissors
with oolong yes I'm serious spoiler
alert beerus wins and begins charging
his blast but Goku's here
running down the top of the ship like a
goof he presents the idea of using
Shenron to help the situation bringing
the Super Saiyan God there for beerus
episode 9. at this point you might have
realized that the story is moving so
goddamn slowly and not in a good way
expanding ideas introducing new elements
that adds more tension and depth to the
story no no I'm talking about the
addition of mindless Meandering useless
scenes that serve no purpose Beyond
bloating a story that was designed for a
film not a series a film in this episode
we are dealing with a portion of the
story that took place an hour into the
film's run time you know the part where
Gohan learns that his wife is pregnant
which allows him to do the ritual for
the Super Saiyan God yeah that part
meaning it's taken nine weeks to get to
this part of the story and if you're
talking about raw time spent combined
with all nine episodes they've stretched
that first hour of the film to over
three hours in the anime and I feel
every agonizing second of it but who
cares Super Saiyan God is here yeah hey
episode 10 Jokes Aside this Arc isn't
all bad and it does eventually start to
show some of its upsides once the fight
between Goku and beerus gets underway on
the Aesthetics front it's not impressive
or anything but the artwork and
character likeness has improved greatly
this episode also moves much more than
perhaps any of the other episodes that
came before it with perhaps episode 5
being an exception though the art for
that was well inspirational as you know
one aspect of the fight within Battle of
Gods I thought lacked in my opinion was
the same thing I thought lacked in
almost any of the Dragon Ball movie
fights how the story builds up the
spectacle of the battle for me a fight
in Dragon Ball is difficult to make feel
epic and Grand when it's only 15 or 20
minutes long within a film the best
battles in Dragon Ball have been long
and for me I only get that Dragon Ball
fight feel when the fight trickles in
episode after episode and in this one
Goku starts to get a handle on the Super
Saiyan God's power and it's a fun
watching all on honesty episode 11 this
episode continues the trend of the last
episode this time improving the
animation introducing more movement and
some wonderful character acting
supervised by totally animator naoke
Tate the choreography is also more
ambitious than the last with the action
greatly ramping up as Goku struggles to
keep up with the increased level of
intensity beerus has introduced to the
conflict as he elevates the contest to
the stratosphere he also plays soccer
with an energy ball just like in Dragon
Ball Fighters
This episode comes to a close with
beerus stabbing Goku in the Torso
sending him lifelessly Falling Towards
the Earth but in true Goku fashion he
finds the strength to Soldier on in the
face of certain Doom next episode and
this is where the show pulls a Dragon
Ball super and disappoints me yet again
so you know the way I was complimenting
the last few episodes for their artwork
and their ability to naturally build
tension well this one sort of throws all
of that out the window and replaces it
with 90 more screaming doing nothing and
executing the exact same move over and
over and over and over again again this
episode makes me bored and angry at the
exact same time which is a weird
combination of emotions I'm riled up but
I'm not interested enough to do anything
about it so anyway Goku and beerus
didn't like the last couple of episodes
and so they decide to Coast on this one
by screaming and clashing fists again
and again also the animator put Goku's
arm on backwards to block this chop from
Barris
I hate this episode episode 13. so we've
made it to the penultimate episode of
The Arc thank God as the fight rages on
from story perspective very little
happens Mr Satan tries to bargain with
whis to no success and as Goku and
beerus continue to fight Goku loses his
God form however despite this Goku
doesn't notice that he continues to push
Bears despite the loss of that form what
is interesting about this episode is not
necessarily the story but that this is
one of the only episodes in the entire
Series where tadayoshi yamamuro the
character designer of the entire series
decided to command the look of this
particular episode he pretty much
redraws over every single piece of
Animation in this one correcting the
character likenesses this is why every
character looks perfectly on model more
so than perhaps any other episode in
this Arc episode 14. in this episode
everything comes to a close pretty much
the same way it did in the Battle of
God's film for the most part
interestingly enough the same animator
That animated this in Dragon Ball super
Broly Rio onashi animated the opening
sequence of this episode's fight between
Goku and beerus flying and fighting
through the water Goku puts up one final
struggle does well but ultimately cannot
deal with beerus before neutralizing his
blast and impressing the God of
destruction this inspires beerus to
spare the Earth well that and he really
liked the food much to the relief of
Goku and the others oh also before I
forget you remember in the Battle of
God's movie where Goku suddenly becomes
overcome by a mysterious Super Saiyan
God powered to stop beerus's blast you
know demonstrating that he can control
the Super Saiyan God power without
ritual do you know that thing that shows
Barris he's worth keeping around well
yeah forget that in super Goku just
punches the blast I'm serious he
literally punches the energy blast
that's all it took apparently cool My
overall thoughts on this season are
probably the worst review I could give
anything it's meh cards are fine but not
spectacular others are downright boring
and bad bits are dotted throughout it's
the most unremarkable I've seen Dragon
Ball in a long while safe poorly
executed and boring except for this part
but little did I know what was to come
around the next Corner watching this
next Arc from start to finish for the
very first time almost broke me it's
time for Resurrection episode 15. Chichi
tells Goku to get to work Satan commands
is adoring public with Tales of how he
defeated beerus as a Super Saiyan no
less and Aliens show up that want to
challenge him yeah this actually happens
thankfully Goku is nearby when this
commotion surfaces and Satan begs him to
deal with the Alien Invaders Goku agrees
but before he gets the chance to fight
Chichi and Piccolo are nearby and that's
what Goku delivers the best joke I've
seen produced by Dragon Ball Goku
basically wants to get away from Chichi
here and he knows that he can't just fly
in front of everybody to get away from
her and so he asks Mr Satan to punch him
away this is what happens
wow
[Music]
10 out of 10 best episode ever
vital skill and it's something I
actually
enjoy a lot but there is nothing worse
than inadequate tools for the job good
sharp knives are essential not just for
ease of use but also safety and kamikoto
have really delivered with their range
of high quality Japanese steel knives
they come in this stunning Ashwood box
which is wonderful for some heavy duty
storage but also makes for a remarkably
looking Christmas gift definitely
something to keep in mind with the
holidays coming up by the way now I am
not the best chef in the world as I'm
sure you can see as I chop up these
vegetables for this gravy I'm making but
that clearly doesn't mean they're not
fit for pros these Japanese steel knives
are used by Michelin star chefs all over
the world thanks to kamikoto's awesome
quality control each knife is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee it's actually kind of
crazy just how sharp they actually are
they really glide through just about
anything which not only looks impressive
but definitely makes me feel much more
secure when cooking there's nothing
quite as scary as trying to push a blunt
knife through a hard vegetable and
worrying about it slipping you
definitely won't run into that issue
with these bad boys that's for sure they
really do look and feel premium each of
these things goes through a 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete kamikoto is
running a massive Black Friday sale
right now too so it's the perfect time
to pick up a set they've also been kind
enough to offer you guys an extra fifty
dollars off any purchase with the
discount code totally not Mark so head
over to kamikoto.com forward slash
totally not marked to help support the
channel
episode 16. The Next Episode kicks off
with some very nostalgic very classic
Dragon Ball Z Art and animation
unfortunately the animator shuichi isaki
only worked on a single episode during
Dragon Ball Super's run but it is cool
to see his work here nonetheless this
episode deals with how Vegeta convinces
whis to take him as his pupil now one of
the aspects I do actually adore from
these first two seasons was the time and
effort taken to link both arcs of this
story together seamlessly instead of
picking up right where the resurrection
F movie does with Goku Vegeta already in
weeks's training it offers new content
that helps set the scene and I love
every minute of it also Vegeta
struggling to cook as well as his
Dynamic with Bulma is always fun to see
episode 17. the last few episodes and
this one included spends a ton of time
focusing on the comedic aspect of Dragon
Ball and honestly I'm here for it to a
degree while I love the scene where Goku
finds out that Vegeta has been training
with weeks for months and burst through
the wall hilariously I really don't like
how childish and [ __ ] at Goku is in the
second half of the episode bogging we
least while he's eating to train him I
think this is the first indication of
stupid super Goku in the series and
unfortunately it's gonna be a trend from
here on out needless to say Goku
convinces whis to train him and so
together they make their way to beerus's
world for what is still to this day one
of my absolute favorite episodes in all
of Dragon Ball super episode 18. I love
everything about this episode the
animation the character acting the
facial expressions the fun the lore the
story it's so fun and it's so Dragon
Ball I'm a huge fan of training episodes
in anime in general some of my most fond
memories from Dragon Ball back in the
day was being in awe at the concept of
snake way alone of seeing King Kai's
world and all of that and so when the
time came for Dragon Ball super to take
a swing at this with whis I was so damn
ready this is the episode I watched more
times than any other episode in Dragon
Ball super I'm I'm not kidding I know
I'm in the minority on this one but this
was honestly such a fun watch dealing
with the weird and crazy training
techniques of whis the Dynamics between
Goku Vegeta and times beerus all the
wild Vegeta dealing with his own
insecurities surrounding the situation
if you haven't seen it check it out it
works as a great Standalone episode 2
and to think this was made by the same
guy who worked on episode 5. it goes to
show time restraints were the cause and
not the Talent episode 19. this episode
covers pretty much the beginning of the
Resurrection F movie following the
freezer Force Reviving their Fallen
leader as well as a little bit of
training with Goku and Vegeta but again
nothing nearly as interesting or as new
as the previous episodes in all there's
really not much to write home about here
it's pretty much the same as the movie
only retold in worse quality and while I
like the theme that plays while Frieza
is revived in Dragon Ball super the tune
that blasted my eardrums in the film was
Next Level hype in comparison episode
20. as I've said in this review time and
again the story rarely deviates much if
at all in any meaningful way from the
original but this time it is different
you see in the movie Frieza kills taguma
but in this he just blasts him a bunch
he'll be used to stall later don't you
worry something of genuine interest as
though is the moment Vegeta and Goku
unlock Super Saiyan blue is actually
shown on screen though in a nebulous
sort of anticlimactic way sort of
fitting for Super Saiyan blue if you ask
me but I'll address that later there's
some more Antics with Jocko a new
character from the galactic Patrol he
warns everyone that Frieza is on his way
by showing off his drawing skills this
was almost the thumbnail for the video I
kid you not but that's everything in
this episode oh Krillin gets a haircut
before giving Master roshi a piggyback
to the action and look it's 10 Shin hunt
episode 21. so the scene is set and all
the Earth's Defenders are there Krillin
roshi tenshinan Gohan and Piccolo
everything is pretty much the exact same
except remember the way taguma didn't
kick the bucket earlier well his
character can now be used to waste even
more time turns out he was frieza's
training partner during his prep for
Goku and because of that training taguma
claims to have gotten incredibly
powerful and while this is explained to
us Goten and Trunks make their way to
the action episode 22. the episode kicks
off as talking about rips off Piccolo's
arm causing Gohan to intervene when out
of nowhere go tank shows off and head
butts him in the groin I wish I was
kidding always good to undercut the
tension of a supposedly dire situation
with a ball joke because gotenk's joke
is now over he conveniently spits up
into Goten and Trunks once again and no
we don't see anything more from them for
the rest of the story I'm glad this
scene happened it was clearly very
important and because the episode is
full of things that literally come out
of nowhere the namekian fraud of the
captain Guinea was trapped inside shows
up write something on the floor taguma
reads it and Ginyu switches bodies with
taguma what in the name of God is
happening as talking as can you talk
about is powering up we cut back to
Vegeta and Goku as they are training in
this special room designed to help them
control their key like a god or
something we then return to the action
as Gohan is going Toe to Toe with Ginyu
until he completely overpowers him using
Super Saiyan Frieza takes this moment to
interject plaster and Gohan with blast
after blast sizing him up for the final
blow when
Yep this actually happens again and I
really hate it there's no emotional
weight to it and it feels cheap and
recycled they can play all the sad music
they want I do not understand the
purpose of this scene and I do not care
episode 23 this one pretty much brings a
story back in line with the resurrection
F movie minus Piccolo's corpse Goku and
Vegeta get out of that Dimension they
were training in Gohan Powers up to Max
looking all sorts of scrawny and Goku
finally reaches the battlefield in time
to deflect a blast along with Vegeta who
shows up to show Ginyu the door in other
words the episode is saying okay
everybody out it's time for act three we
gotta get back on schedule next episode
24. these episodes Absolutely suck and
now episode 27 the final episode of the
okay fine I'll go back and talk about
them
episode 24 25 and 26 are absolutely
brutal to get through especially when
they first aired but even if you're
talking about the remaster that
corrected a lot of that downright
terrible artwork the animation is still
embarrassingly poor again I'm not
lumping the blame onto the animators
here they are the victims during this
time period the stat behind each episode
would receive copious amounts of
ridicule and scrutiny from online and
the local public completely undeserved
mind you simply because people didn't
understand the time restraints the brass
at toei put on their schedules some
episodes during this time period had to
be completed in six weeks less than half
of the time a normal episode should have
to be created all of that aside however
the episodes demonstrate Dragon Ball
super at their most visually
uninterested flat compositions
unimaginative choreography and
ridiculously boring back and forth
between Frieza and Goku these three
episodes demonstrated exactly why
recreating the films was a boring idea
sitting through this solid hour of bad
super episodes was unbearable to say the
least if you don't believe me check them
out for yourself episode 27 okay we're
finally here episode 27 and the final
episode of The Arc and it's actually all
right it's not amazing and it's not
really better than the film in many
regards but in one way it actually is I
felt during the film I was waiting for
Vegeta to finally get his hands on
Frieza and what he did it was amazing
and cathartic but it was over way way
too soon in this they actually allow him
to school and style and Frieza for a
little while longer it's nice but again
the majority of the episode is nothing
to write home about outside of that one
instance oh also the music that plays
when Frieza blows up the planet is
terribly suited to the moment it's not
sad it's not even disastrous it's a
track that would be better suited to the
reveal of a Super Saiyan God sort of an
uplifting ethereal track and when
bulma's cries of Anguish over the loss
of her family ring through that
uplifting number there's the worst sense
of Music misplacement it just feels so
wrong
and that describes a lot of the music
throughout these first seasons of Dragon
Ball super supplied by Sumitomo the
composer for this series now he is a
great composer I mean he created the
soundtrack for Dragon Ball super Broly
and that has some of my favorite music
to be supplied for Dragon Ball in a long
long time unfortunately for Dragon Ball
super the music met the same fate as the
animation as the pre-production window
given to the series was far far too
short to create a solid artistic vision
and a solid Musical soundtrack and that
pretty much concludes Dragon Ball
Super's rehashed retellings of the
Battle of Gods and Resurrection f movies
yikes I can on some level understand the
creative team's desire to remake the
films it is extremely important for the
viewers at home to understand and know
why a purple cat monster is eating food
next to a flamboyant blue Hollister
model but on the other hand the material
they added absolutely did not justify
the 14 episodes dedicated to each of
these individual sagas for long expanses
of these arcs so much of it was
incredibly boring and so many of the
gags didn't work for me with that said
there are some bright spots to these 27
episodes that I did enjoy as I said I
did like how they linked these two sagas
together and episode 18 is always a
treasure gem in this ocean of mediocrity
but overall the first two arcs I
genuinely believe could have been
skipped in favor of the films that do a
much better job save for perhaps the
first few episodes of the Resurrection F
Saga and now that we have the movie
adaptation arcs out of the way it's
finally time to transition into
something a lot more interesting in my
opinion and that is Super's third
official Arc the universe 6 tournament
Arc
foreign
for me to say that the Recreations of
the Battle of Gods of Resurrection F
films didn't exactly set the world on
fire but instead Towing animation and
Dragon Ball Super's reputations across
the entire world you simply couldn't
escape it plastered on every Forum on
every social media that would mention
Dragon Ball super the memes were
unavoidable fans clearly were not happy
we were tired of remix we wanted
something new and boy did we not know
anything about how the animation
industry worked back then things
needless to say were not going all that
well for Dragon Ball super then enter
the universe 6 tournament Arc let's see
how this goes episode 28 the episode
itself kicks off as Goku and Vegeta are
training on beerus's world under whis
seen doing 50 000 one thumb one arm
handstand push-ups while wearing
incredibly heavy clothing out of nowhere
a blast crashes in the surrounding
Forest waking up in angry beerus that
begins attacking Goku and Vegeta who as
we previously established can barely
move it turns out beerus's brother
Champa Who We Are told is fat in a
number of different and creative ways
desires to challenge his brother to a
food competition Champa much like beerus
with his seventh universe is Universe
6's God of destruction having gathered
the most delicious food his Universe had
to offer beerus brings some delicious
food from Earth to combat Universe 6's
best efforts Goku calls Champa fat once
again reinforcing this to us in case we
forgot in the last 6 minutes and
universe 7 wins the food competition
thanks to some cup noodles Champa
because of this desires to locate his
universe's Earth for their food but
finds out that it has long since been
destroyed during this Exposition we find
out a host of information regarding the
universe's in Dragon Ball super and how
they work each Universe has a sister
universe that they share a ton of
similarities with totaling 12 universes
in all each one governed by an Angel and
God of destruction Pearson Champa began
to squabble leading to their respective
attendance having to step in to stop the
conflict Champa then suggests that since
they can't fight each other they should
host a tournament between their
respective universes a 5v5 tournament
where the winner stays on to face the
next with the winner receiving the Super
Dragon Balls beerus agrees and so Begins
the arc I actually found this opening to
be pretty good again not amazing but it
hit all the marks introduced and
established two vital characters the
plot of the coming episodes and I'm
always down for a good tournament so
bring it on episode 29 beerus decides to
leave it up to Goku Vegeta to figure out
who their remaining teammates would be
for Universe 7 with one caveat the
captain is to be a mysterious Warrior of
beerus's choosing who is according to
him much stronger than Goku we fast
forward to Earth where Bulma hits beerus
again establishes a plan to use the
Earth's Dragon Balls to find the Super
Dragon Balls before Champa does all the
while he and vados are off creating the
tournament grounds however Shenron
doesn't know where the last remaining
Super Dragon Ball is thus Bulma is
forced to create a Super Dragon Ball
radar that she makes with ease by the
way and hey she has a sister I guess
using her sister titus's contacts Jaco
and Bulma now make out a plan to search
for the super dragon balls while Goku
and Vegeta find teammates it's a nice
little episode establishing the stakes
and unpacking all the setup of the prior
episode for us to better understand what
the consequences are within the world
episode 30. this episode is trash I'm
not even going to spend much time on it
it's just a crappy recap episode of the
last two episodes and maybe a little bit
of the other stuff but I'm serious the
point is Goku and Vegeta recruit Piccolo
and boo done next episode 31. this
episode is really weird I mean I like it
but I also don't so let me explain the
episode is centered around the antics of
Bulma and Jaco the galactic patrol
officer as they pursue an individual
called zuno that by Jaco's own
description can answer any question
asked of him he's sort of an all-knowing
being and don't worry I'll address that
in a second but once they arrive they
realize that they require an appointment
an appointment that they don't have and
the appointment waiting list is quite
long so it's a good thing that the
person ahead of Jocko in the line was a
low-life criminal that takes one of the
servants hostage Jaco incapacitates the
criminal with ease nabbing his place in
line wow that's convenient and once
inside they gave the big zun man some
smooches bulma's official cup sizes
revealed and zuno answers bulma's
question about the Super Dragon Balls I
thought this episode was funny and
interesting in parts and really forced
and lazy in others I enjoyed the mains
with which Bulma and Jaco gain access to
the question room but I hated that there
just happened to be a criminal there
before like what are the odds of that
actually happening additionally I like
the idea of Bulma taking the initiative
to think of a way that she can gain the
upper hand without Force like the others
do showing that she is an active
character in her own right that will do
what she can to protect the Earth too
but the fact that there is a plot device
McGuffin character that knows everything
is absolutely ridiculous and is
horrendously lazy he was literally
created to teach us about the Super
Dragon Balls nothing else well we did
get the cup size but who the hell cares
about that because the tournament is
starting in the next episode episode 32.
what can I say I'm a simple man I hear a
tournament is coming and I get excited
this episode does contain the star of
the tournament sort of but it also has a
whole bunch of setup but it's fun setup
so I dig it the episode kicks off with
Goku and Vegeta inside the room of
spirit in time or hyperbolic Time
Chamber depending on your persuasion as
they train for three years upon exiting
said room or chamber both Vegeta and
Goku have beards and stink like nothing
else so that's fun whis has prepared a
cube transporter to carry the combatants
and The Spectators to the area Champa
and fattos have created the tournament
grounds within they meet monaka the
strongest in Universe 7 apparently and
Goku punches him in the face what a
weird thing to do to someone you just
met they arrive at the tournament
grounds meet the competitors and take a
test to make sure they aren't mindless
Goku scrapes by with a pass and Majin
Buu falls asleep entirely already the
team of universe 7 is down to just four
Fighters Goku Piccolo Vegeta and of
course monaka who beers and CIS goes
last Goku opts to fight first against
the Xi Jinping looking character named
botamo and a penguin alien sings the
national anthem of the universe ending
the episode episode 33. okay so we
didn't get much action in the last
episode but in this one we get the
conclusion to two fights count them two
fights Goku versus the president of
China is up first and Goku gets off to a
rough start but mostly due to him not
having digested his food from the trip
over properly he starts warping up doing
some squats and jogging as he Dodges
botamo's blasts he eventually warms up
and starts going on the offensive but
quickly realizes that this isn't going
to be as straightforward as he once
anticipated butamo you see has the
ability to absorb a seemingly infinite
amount of physical punishment without
any damage sustained to himself however
with that revealed the means with which
Goku can defeat him becomes clear Judo
throwing the bear out of bounds the
winner of the first fight is Goku and so
Goku moves on to the next round to fight
Universe 6's second combatant Frost who
looks like Frieza only you know but blue
and apparently not evil in fact he has a
reputation in Universe 6 as being a very
good person according to Kaaba the
Saiyan from Universe 6 Frost is a
peacekeeper in his Universe acting on
behalf of the week that can't defend
themselves however once he starts
fighting with Goku it becomes clear that
he can't keep up with the Saiyan
especially after assuming his super
saying for it which came much to come a
surprise as he has never seen that form
before apparently without seemingly
trying he puts frost on the back foot
catching his initial attacks
effortlessly beating him to a pulp
causing his legs to buckle and Shake
beneath him Goku requests a frost to
quit but he refuses moving in for one
more punch which again is blocked by
Goku without much effort but this time
something's wrong Goku Falls weary and
frost capitalizes on this by knocking
the sand out of bounds Goku is
eliminated now that's what I call a
cliffhanger Episode 34 Frost has
eliminated Son Goku much to paris's
dismay and so next up is Piccolo Piccolo
begins dodging Frost initial attacks
opting to immediately charge his Macan
Coast to Poe or special beam Cannon
depending on your persuasion through
clever movements the utilization of some
defensive techniques and a long
underutilizability of his to stretch his
arms Piccolo restrains Frost as he
readies himself to release his finishing
attack when suddenly as Frost moves his
arm Piccolo 2 becomes weary and drowsy
creating an opening for frost to take
out Piccolo completely incapacitating
him it seems the Frost has won the match
however this time Jocko has an objection
armed with fantastic eyesight he noticed
that Frost much like during his fight
with Goku has broken the rules utilizing
a Barb on his wrist coated in a fast
acting neurotoxin this is considered
cheating and so both Piccolo and Goku
are reinstated and it turns out Frost is
actually Super Evil and in fact causes
the war as he acts as a peacekeeper for
once this is revealed Vegeta insists
that Piccolo stands aside for him to
fight Frost which he does without
complaint next up Vegeta vs Frost I
still don't understand why Piccolo is
eliminated now for opting to switch
places with Vegeta but whatever episode
35 this episode like many of the others
that came before it deals with quite a
lot it feels like and to be honest this
entire Arc has paced itself rather well
I think maybe one or two episodes were a
little slow and one episode was entirely
recapped but the vast majority has been
quite good at staggering its plot points
and story beats effectively in this
episode episode Vegeta eliminates Frost
with one lonely punch Frost tries to
steal the tournament earnings while the
next match is being set up hit
intervenes however and incapacitates
frost turns out hits rather strong who
knew before the next fight begins Champa
creates a new rule the next match will
take place within a large box of sorts
anyway it becomes clear as to why he
does this as the match pushes forward
while magetta the third fighter from
Universe 6 can't fly he is incredibly
strong and gives off tons of steam
causing the arena to warm up
dramatically with Super Saiyan alone not
working for Vegeta and the air running
out in the arena how will he deal with
this new foe episode 36 Vegeta getting
desperate throws everything at this tin
Titan only to have it either be thrown
back in his face or for it to have
little to no effect at all gallic guns
punches kicks and evasive maneuvers
having achieved little to nothing for
the same other than a very close almost
lost by way of wring out causing Vegeta
to lose his temper forcing him to use
the most powerful technique in his
Arsenal the final Flash the charge here
is honestly quite nostalgic taking a lot
of cues and visuals from the original
one in the cell Saga the lightning
surrounding the Saiyan spreads far and
wide as it envelops the entire planet
they are fighting on cutting up the land
and Arena floor like butter Vegeta
readies his blast takes aim and fires it
towards magetta who to everyone's
surprise takes it like a champ Vegeta
then follows us up with a massive punch
and some insults which honestly affected
him much more than any of his attacks
ever did leading to the universe 6
fighter getting knocked out of bounds
the match is over Vegeta is the Victor
and Ugg comes the next opponent for him
the Saiyan from Universe 6 Kaaba episode
37. in this episode we get introduced to
one of my favorite Dynamics to develop
from Dragon Ball super period and it all
starts here the match begins Vegeta and
Kaba soon discover that they are pretty
well matched in their base form however
the situation for Kaaba becomes clear
when he reveals he has never heard of a
Super Saiyan and cannot change into one
and in the middle of the fight he
requests Vegeta to teach him this
appears to enrage the prince as he
explodes into Super Saiyan knocking
Kaaba for a loop with a single blow like
frost before him he batters and bruises
the boy before grabbing him by the
Scruff of his neck looking straight into
his eyes promising to destroy his home
and his family with all of this in the
back of kaaba's mind it incites a
dramatic transformation within it he's
done it he's achieved the Legendary
Super Saiyan form and as he explores his
new powers and strength the Saiyan
Prince Vegeta cracks a smile apparently
this had been his plan the entire time
this was
training comma he tells him to keep
pushing himself to never accept his
limit and to let the difference between
Vegeta and himself fuel his efforts
Vegeta transforms into Super Saiyan blue
shocking Kaaba yet again the reflection
of Vegeta in his eyes vanishes from
kaaba's View and before he even
registers his disappearance Kaaba Falls
the floor defeated Vegeta's last words
never forget this pain it's a great
episode and wonderfully establishes a
story and role for Vegeta to assume as a
teacher for the Next Generation but
there's no time for celebration because
Vegeta has steamrolled through three of
universe 6's team now remains their Ace
in the Hole their final fighter hit the
Assassin episode 38 alrighty so this
episode and the next are sort of where
all the best action and business occurs
in the arc but despite the next episode
having everyone's favorite moment I
genuinely feel this episode is the best
one and we get a rare shot of some blood
too which if we are talking about modern
Dragon Ball is really rare the episode
kicks things off with Vegeta now on his
fourth opponent hit the final contestant
from Universe 6 the Bell Rings The Ref
shouts Hajime and Vegeta burst into
Super Saiyan blue now this is something
I thought was kind of weird Vegeta
actually comments on the weak stance it
assumes from the very beginning but
Vegeta is standing like this arms down
front facing with his face exposed
leaning forward not only is this a
terrible fighting stance on a
fundamental level by Vegeta but this is
also the first time I've ever seen him
take a stance like this in this series
at the first sign of movement hit zooms
into action Vegeta remarking that he's
very fast before taking a knuckle to the
mouth instead of taking things slowly
Vegeta launches forward before once
again being swatted to the side with a
strike to his neck the fight progresses
much like this more and more blows
Landon Vegeta as he continues to lose
power to hit remarking to himself that
he can't seem to see his movements at
all and so he devises a plan he allows
hit to land a strike on him but this
time he catches the punch once he
absorbs it this catches even the
incredible hit off guard and now with
the assassins grasp he can no longer die
Vegeta falls to the floor lifeless hit
is the winner as the match wraps up Goku
and Jaco discuss hit and his movement
with Jocko someone who prides himself on
his ability to see remarks that it's
like hit completely disappears while
he's attacking the king of the galactic
Patrol who is also there sorry I sort of
glanced over that part at the beginning
he says that it could be a technique
known as the time skip a technique that
skips segments of time up to 0.1 seconds
allowing the wielder to attack unseen
Goku then makes his way over to the
starting point passing Vegeta on his way
he asks if he has any advice for him
Vegeta doesn't have any apparently whis
at this time has the knowledge necessary
to give Goku an advantage here or to at
least level the playing field but he
sees this as training reassuring beerus
in a joking manner that they still have
Universe 7's strongest fighter monaka
waiting in the wings monaka it's
revealed is a fraud without being aware
of this Goku is Universe 7's Last Hope
the fight begins yeah this is all in the
the same Episode by the way there really
is a lot in this one it's definitely an
underrated episode I think because of
its proximity to the next episode it
goes on to ask Goku why he hasn't
transformed Goku explains that he
doesn't
and he wants to save his stamina for
later the attacks from Goku come from a
number of different angles all while
evading and faking shots all to no avail
hit at this point recommends that he
give up as taking so many hits to his
vital areas could end very poorly for
him Goku smirks and refuses because
apparently he's found an opening Goku
launches forward moves to strike but
instead blocks anticipating his
technique once blocked switching again
to offensive Goku swings his fist
towards the time skipping assassin
grazing his cheek with his knuckle and
look purple blood spoiled in this
episode we are Goku attacks again
anticipates the attack blocks it and
anticipates where he'll move once again
Landing his second consecutive
unanswered blow the two go on to explain
that they will start taking things
seriously from this point on ending the
episode episode 39. this episode is
pretty much all action kicking things
off off in Super Saiyan blue we see hits
perspective of attack for the first time
as he is once again taken off guard by
Goku only this time he lands Square on
his back attack after attack Goku is
getting the better of the Assassin
couple this with some wonderfully
unmodel artwork and you have yourself
some great scenes it does some sort of
fake power-up explains that he's not
like Goku and the others and can't just
power up by screaming and we'll just
have to improve on the Fly using his own
abilities and he does just that
increasing the scope of his time skip
longer and longer because of this
Improvement Goku is knocked to the floor
once again with another heavy series of
attacks struggling to his feet he
reveals that he has to resort to his
secret weapon a technique not yet
perfected that runs with a massive risk
now where have I heard that before
that's freaking right my absolute
favorite move in all of Dragon Ball has
made a guest appearance in Dragon Ball
super as the big finish to the battle
I'm obligated to like this as a result I
can totally see why this is a lot of
people's favorite moment I mean how
could you not it's incredibly exciting
don't not spectacularly built up to by
any means but not bad either I suppose
the aspect of this that I really enjoyed
was how I wasn't expecting it and how it
sort of made sense to couple it with
Super Saiyan blue given how we know that
farm works I remember seeing this for
the first time at like 1am lying in bed
trying to contain my excitement the
entire arena is enveloped in the red
glow of the Kaio cave Goku is too fast
and explodes from the arena Landing a
clean strike against the freshly powered
up hit he charges and fires his
Kamehameha at hit ending the episode
quite the finale episode 40. oh but wait
it's uh it's not the finale Goku and hit
go back and forth a bit longer but it's
obvious that the best part of the
fighting is over really eventually
Goku's body starts giving him trouble
before he chooses to Forfeit the match
entirely refusing to act as a pawn for
beerus and Champa besides now it's
monaka's turn he gets to watch him fight
it recognizes his sacrifice and repays
his debt to Goku by throwing the match
against monaka too Universe 7 is the
winner monaka the Victor Champa is
extremely angry and threatens to destroy
his losing team that he created but it's
cut short as some tiny figure flanked by
some tall gentleman arrive on the stage
beerus and Champa look worried episode
41 it's revealed that this is Lord Zeno
he's pretty much the superior tibera
Champa and everyone really including the
Angels Goku being Goku walks up to Zeno
and Strikes up a conversation Zeno
actually really likes him then a
reprimands beerus and Champa before
announcing that he did really like this
tournament and that he would hold a
tournament similar to this in the future
after that it's time to make the wish in
the Super Dragon Balls apparently the
last one that they were looking for was
the very Planet they were fighting on
the dragon is called forth and look it
looks embarrassingly bad like like
really poor clip art kind of bad it
looks awful and the wish is made
whatever beerus wishes that champa's
Universe Got Its Earth back it was the
sweet wish whatever and that's Dragon
Ball Super's third Arc just when things
were at their worst Dragon Ball super
delivered some of its best well maybe
that's going a little too far I mean the
animation largely was okay not
spectacular the story was very by the
books despite some moments of genuine
interest here and there it is a million
miles better than the first arcs but why
don't I have better things to say about
this one well despite me really getting
a kick out of the Kaioken moment the
fight between Goku and hit is really
lazy I thought the beginning is by far
the best part watching Goku feel out the
situation trying to figure it out but
the second half is just move after move
coming out of seemingly nowhere to even
or flip the odds in favor of the next
fighter hit just randomly gets better I
mean I I don't get anything out of that
it's not interesting also it's a
tournament Arc that didn't have a
resolution a final winner well I mean it
sort of did I mean Morocco but come on
is that how you want to end this
yes I hear the comment section screams
let's not forget that this is less than
a third of the way through the series
for what awaits us after this is the
wickedly popular and massively confusing
Goku black Ark
Dragon Ball Super's Goku blacker it
doesn't make any sense not an ounce
milliliter or whatever your preferred
unit of measurement is and I emphasize
this because this Arc broke my brain now
I'm not gonna lie to you guys this is
gonna test our relationship more than
that one episode of Dragon Ball super
where Barry Khan tries to convince Videl
that her good boy Gohan was cheating on
her with actual photographic evidence
and yes that actually happens but more
importantly I need you guys to be my
Videl on this one during this video I
might say some things that you might
disagree with but through all of this I
will try to explain myself as best I can
and that I love you I need you to look
at this picture of me kissing Goku black
I understand that I'm doing this not
because I want to God no no I'm kissing
Goku black because I have to for us I'm
doing this for us now this point I'm
aware that this is starting to look like
I'm stalling and that's because you're
right while I do remember enjoying this
Arc of the show I'm also keenly aware
that it doesn't make a single ounce of
sense and I fear that my second trip
around the block might tip me over the
edge but again I do this for us so
hold on there were a number of Filler
episodes that took place between this
Arc and the last five episodes in total
to be exact They Don't Really connect
anything and could easily be cut without
any consequence to the continuity but
because I know you're going to ask my
opinion on them here it is super fast
episode 42 totally fine somewhat fun
episode where we get a rematch between
Goku and beerus sort of it's some Slice
of Life harmless fun to help unwind
after the tournament nothing major
episode 43 this is a really weird
episode that introduces what I thought
was at the time a new mechanic Goku
losing control of his key due to his use
of Super Saiyan blue in tandem with the
Kaioken technique but it turned out to
be a once-off never again having
consequence in the rest of the series
today despite Goku using that exact same
tandem technique a number of times
thereafter episodes 44 45 and 46 this
fillerack is something that I thought
could have been quite good actually but
was only okay really at the end of the
day the first episode is largely set up
and boring the second episode is
interesting getting to see Vegeta deal
with the loss of his power and the third
is a really underwhelming rematch of the
Goku vs Vegeta fight overall I thought
these were mostly boring and nothing to
write home about okay it's time for
black
[Music]
episode 47 this is the best first
episode to any Arc of any Dragon Ball
anything I have ever seen ever this
might also be the single most
interesting and compelling Dragon Ball
villain introduction to show once again
has ever unveiled at least to me all the
parts are there opening effectively and
fast by setting the scene establishing
the hero and the current objective
remaining undetected by a shadowy figure
in the sky trunks's reality really can
seem to catch a break here and it's not
even five minutes in then his mom dies
in a really tragic way right in front of
him before he's given the responsibility
to flee to the Past once again to search
for help we then get introduced to Mai
oh my similar in age now to trunks their
relationship is also given time to
breathe as they eat cat food again
showing how dire the situation is for
their timeline once again trunks this
time with my runs into the shadowy
figure in the sky on their way back to
the time machine Mai is taken out but
not really and finally the shadowy
figure is revealed
okay though for real when this episode
first aired literally everyone had that
face on ironically episode 48 the best
part
episode are its beginning and end
clearly it's beginning
my trunks is still delivered by the
looming threat of Goku book and so is
forced into direct conflict once again
this is a great continuation from the
previous episode keeping the tone and
the drama intact trunks manages to
distract Goku black long enough to peace
out from that timeline and land himself
into the present main timeline we are
familiar with leaving GB all kinds of
confused some stuff with Trunks and
Goten in school takes place future
Trump's arrives causing everyone to wig
out and everyone dashes to the rescue he
zaptive energy and out cold Goku gets
some beans corn and yajirobi are playing
limbo and Trunks wakes up
next episode 49 okay so this fight it
doesn't actually happen unless you mean
this fight that's totally unrelated and
happens like 10 minutes later in which
case yes that absolutely happens trunks
is brought up to speed
he even explains how he dealt with Majin
Buu which is a nice touch I think before
going on to explain the whole evil Goku
Stitch his timeline has been dealing
with how almost all of humanity has been
destroyed and that they are in a pretty
desperate situation beerus and whis are
not too happy about this time
manipulation which honestly doesn't tell
me anything other than that the writers
needed a way for bears and whis to not
get involved with trunks's timeline
which again if I'm being perfectly
honest is probably the most
straightforward thing they did during
this Arc oh and Goku black discovers
that trunks escape to another time
before following him and showing up at
the end of this episode in the present
clue hanger episode 50. I really like
this episode and it's so pretty this
episode is supervised by yuichi karasawa
and I just think it looks pretty okay
but like most things I have my issues
with it I'll get all the bad out of the
way first it's clear that the writers
didn't put a ton of care into getting
Goku and Goku black into the same space
for their first encounter it's explained
that Goku black followed the tear in
Time trunks's Time Machine left behind
and I'm like okay but then he gets
pulled back in time because the tear is
closing or something like what look just
say it you wanted Goku and Goku black to
fight and this was the only way you
could make it work while also keeping
them apart but whatever aside from that
the fight between Goku black and Goku
has some seriously polished and crisp
artwork while also showcasing some
really interesting and fun fight
choreography it also stands in direct
contrast with the rest of the arc which
spoiler alert is completely shrouded in
darkness like 90 of the time before
piecing out black destroys trunks's time
machine for some reason I thought he
wanted trunks to be destroyed why would
he get rid of his only way to the Future
to be fair that is a minor nitpick and
maybe black made a last minute decision
not a big deal thankfully though once
everything calms down Bulma reveals that
she kept the extra time machine cell
used during the cell's Saga that's a
really cool throwback and one that
really does a fantastic job at linking
the past with the present of super in
fact I'd go as far as to say that it's
the best callback to the past so far
easily I don't think I would ever have
even thought of that episode 51. Mai is
an older lady trapped inside a kid body
whose best friends are a dog and a small
Gremlin man to me her having a thing
with trunks is weird and I can't shake
that also this episode is total filler
and completely boring Goku goes off the
train in King Kai's beerus and whis are
suspicious of the key given off by Goku
black and the evil boy's plans are late
to Bear next episode 52 another filler
nothing episode that I found insanely
boring which is weird because the
beginning of the ACT did such a great
job of sucking me in and getting the
tension going much like the last episode
Bulma is still working on the time
machine repairing it what follows
honestly it doesn't really impact
anything it could be removed and nothing
would change trunks tracks down Gohan to
meet up they eat ice cream and have
dinner go on having ice cream before
dinner
if you're a fan of Gohan and enjoy this
interaction I get it but I personally
found it to be a pointless distraction
and very boring when trunks returns home
from his day of debauchery with dragon
Ball's bad boy he finds out that beerus
whis and Goku are traveling to another
Universe to investigate the mysterious
key of Goku Black episode 53 I actually
really really like this episode it's
mostly talking but does have some action
a decent chunk of comedy with stupid
super Goku but more importantly deals
with introduces and establishes the
foundational motivations for one of the
most important characters in The Arc
zamasu the individual next in line to be
the Supreme Kai of universe 10. there's
a nice exchange between gowasu the
current Supreme Kai of universe 10 and
his pupil zamasu who upon entering the
scene presents tea to his master kuasu
explains that the tea is a reflection of
his pure heart and as a result will
taste wonderful with the focus on the
teacup itself zamasu goes on to ask
owasu questions regarding Mankind's
deservedness of their watchful eye this
conflicted Outlook in zamasu's head also
clouds the tea glasses drink thinking
and he notices this I thought that was a
really nice inclusion there's a whole
mess of stupid super Goku being annoying
that I'm choosing to ignore and Skip
because I hate it the fight between
zamasu and Goku is actually interesting
and fun albeit short facilitating An
Elegant way for beerus and wheeze to
better understand who black really is
episode 54. there are a bunch of
episodes that happen after the initial
story beats are ironed out that really
feel like padding trunks chilling out my
in the peel off gang doing various
things and now more waiting around while
Bulma adds the finishing touches to The
Time Machine thankfully though in this
episode we finally get something at
least a little bit interesting we
haven't really as I've yet had a chance
to see Vegeta and Trunks interact much
since he returned and so if nothing else
this scene needed to take place Vegeta
spars with trunks testing his abilities
introducing trunks of Super Saiyan blue
and finally instilling within him the
desire to always strive to be stronger
the episode itself ends proper as
zamasu's disillusionment Arc continues
to spiral out of control his master
gowasu seeing this decides to show
zamasu the time rings how to use them
and decides to bring the young Kai into
the future of a particular race of
Mortals on planet Barbary episode 55. so
the point gowasu was trying to make
forzamasu on planet barbary's future
completely backfires and only reinforces
the belief zamasu already held on too
tightly now having seen his master
shocked by the events that took place
under his own control zamasu now has all
the proof he needs to know that what he
feels is in fact correct he must enact
his plan to eradicate Humanity on the
other side of things Zeno requests Goku
to come over he wants to be friends with
him apparently Zeno really likes him and
decides to give Goku a button and not
just any button a two-sided button that
can bring Goku to Zeno or Zeno to Goku
depending on which side he presses
beerus naturally is terrified at the
idea of this for obvious reasons the
episode ends with Goku Vegeta and Trunks
finally boarding the now finally
repaired time machine and arriving in
trunks's future however upon arrival
they get attacked almost immediately by
the Earth's remaining forces episode 56
hold your fire this may man isn't black
what and people said Dragon Ball doesn't
have social commentary for real though
this episode is actually quite good and
I really enjoyed it it's the first time
the characters from Goku's timeline get
to see trunks's affected future and man
is it in a wreck we follow future Maya
as Sheila is the resistance against Goku
black before she leads trunks Goku and
Vegeta through the catacombs and Subways
they are forced to live in so few people
remain Left Alive and she blames herself
for not being strong enough or enough to
protect them all Goku and everyone puts
this insecurity to rest quickly
thankfully these small character
interactions felt very genuine and set
the tone for the upcoming battles
brilliantly this is what trunks is
fighting for the little children
soldiers and families all living in
squalor and fear underneath the streets
of their destroyed and tortured World
Vegeta feels confident and ready leading
in the challenge Goku black right away
black arrives on the scene they fight
leading to Black revealing his Ace and
behold Super Saiyan Rose appears and
Vegeta is taken out immediately because
of course he is I guess someone has to
act as the sacrificial lamb to create
create the Cliffhanger for this episode
episode
action whether that's a good
suggest we'll find out on a visual front
first and for
simple super has delivered so far
supplied by natoshi Shira a fantastic
action animator famous at this point for
working on the original Dragon Ball Z
anime and for supplying that awesome
Cloud fight sequence between Goku and
beerus in the Battle of Gods movie and
no this will not be the last time we see
his work in Dragon Ball super or even
this Arc so get hyped for that but even
taking that shortcut he supplied out the
artwork Direction and and in part
animation within this episode are
largely far above the series average
which is honestly a great sign from a
story point of view this is where things
start getting really silly though while
Goku being able to keep up with black is
somewhat believable trunks doing so is
most certainly not someone who was being
schooled by black in his base State
while he was in Super Saiyan form should
not be able to do what he's doing in
this scene against a super powered Super
Saiyan Rose Goku black it's ridiculous
and makes zero sense even with his
little rage boost which I wonder how
many more of those we're gonna get they
get defeated by black and zamasu but
thankfully are rescued by yajirobi and
Mai sending them back to the pass in a
beaten Heat I guess it's back to the
drawing board episode 58 zuno fills
zamasu in on all that he needs to know
about the super dragon balls and we'd
cut back to the house where we see more
stupid super Goku he forgot to bring the
senzu beans that they prepared wait what
he forgot yeah you know he forgot you
know because Goku
forces I mean senzu beans and blacks
forces I sit back in my chair cringing
again another moment where the writing
staff had no idea how to create a scene
without compromising either logic or
character could you imagine the Goku who
prepared for the Androids making this
mistake the answer no episode 59 so in
this episode beerus whis shin and Goku
because he needs to be in almost every
episode for some reason arrive in
universe tend to try to figure out if
zamasu is in fact Sinister they can't
exactly reprimand him just yet as
technically he hasn't done anything too
wrong yet and so they need to test him
for proof and they do pretty much just
that samasu does the doongowasu Reese
rewinds time and beerus akaism out of
existence it's a cool scene punctuated
beautifully by the score but there's not
much to it in the way of narrative
structure it's just cool to finally see
beerus actually do something also beerus
is convinced that this will fix all the
timelines despite everyone knowing that
that's not how time travel Works in
Dragon Ball other than that in this
episode trunks has a pep talk with
trunks so that's weird albeit sort of
cute episode 60. so the gang decided to
go back to the future to see if the
timeline has been miraculously fixed
thanks to beerus can I just ask why are
they going back nothing about them is
different here they are just as strong
and unprepared as they were before only
this time they have senzu beans they
were completely outmatched last time
this is one of those moments in the
anime that I think works far better in
the manga now I am intentionally haven't
mentioned the manga because I wanted to
focus on the anime here primarily but
for the sake of this point I'll use it
as reference in the anime they go to the
Future three times in the manga they go
just twice once they fail they regroup
and prepare as best they can before
returning finally for the last time they
didn't do this in the anime until the
third time for some reason fool me once
shame on you so they go back to the
future and just when I thought they
could make Goku's character any weirder
they decide that he needed to have this
bit of exposition
foreign
[Music]
like he has two sons think about that
how creepy is that well thankfully B and
Z show up to save this awkward scene and
Vegeta finally attacks episode 61 so
it's revealed that zamasu is Immortal
finally and that Goku black took out
Goku already in a different timeline I'm
not going to try to make sense of this
tiny whimey stuff right now because it
doesn't actually make any sense if you
really think about it and I value what's
left of my sanity right now we see
zamasu and Goku Black Hog for a little
too long but you know name a more iconic
couple Jennifer Aniston and Brad Pitt
eat your heart out it's revealed to Goku
how black disposed of his family and him
which leads to Goku getting all sorts of
mad now don't get me wrong it is a cool
scene but it's difficult for me to
understand why he wouldn't be just as
upset like that over bullmadine I guess
because he has to have those hilarious
scenes where he acts like an idiot
around zamasu maybe what would Dragon
Ball super do without that Goku black
pulls a weird new move out of his butt I
mean discovers new depths to his power
and takes Goku out once again black
starts posturing and gloating and making
all sorts of evil noises as trunks looks
on leading to trunks receiving his
second unreasonable power boost of the
Ark at least this time it looks cool
episode 62. okay it doesn't look cool
anymore it looks awful make it stop
please make it stop okay so get this
trunks on his own holds off a super
powered Goku black and an immortal
zamasu while Goku and Vegeta both Escape
back to the past for a second time Goku
literally starts laughing about how he
punched himself to Chichi and Vegeta
flies off to better himself before the
next fight like he should have done the
last time oh and actually okay Goku
heads over to Master Roshi's to learn
the mafuba which if I'm being completely
honest is an ingenious way of dealing
with an immortal villain that I
personally had forgotten about episode
63 meanwhile in the future Mai decides
that the best course of action that she
should take is to shoot Goku black
with a gun yep well that didn't work and
oh look another unrealistic fight scene
showing trunks acting way way more
powerful than he should be if this story
actually made sense but at least it
looks pretty so black stabs trunks
through the Torso with his energy blade
and a few moments later trunks his back
up on his feet smiling again that's neat
want to share that power with the rest
of the class trunks as soon as Vegeta
Bulma and Goku arrive back in the future
to help trunks black destroys the time
machine immediately which is honestly a
good idea okay look there's been silly
moments in this show so far but they
have a good plan right now with the
mafuba and there's time to deliver a
great third act so fingers crossed let's
do this Goku and Vegeta start fighting
black and zamosu Vegeta just wrecks
black and it's really satisfying
satisfying because you know how much it
means for Vegeta to take revenge on the
guy that defeated him personally and who
ruined his son's life it's a great scene
with some classic Vegeta one lighters
episode 64. Vegeta continues to school
on black until black blur is that
Saiyans get their power through anger
and then stabs his own hand to turn his
energy sword into his Scythe just in
case the Grim Reaper metaphor wasn't
lost in any of us it's at this point
Goku black turns into a ridiculous
character crapping out new techniques
without he even knowing what the hell is
going on like it gets really silly well
this is all happening trunks learns the
MAF about in like a few moments and
captures zamasu perfectly it turns out
that Goku once again kind of forgot they
aren't Fleet and euron's forces he
forgot the damn seal for the motherboard
to actually work I hate this Arc this
was a great way for the story to dispose
of immortal character and now it goes
right down the toilet I guess it's time
to go full marketing dummy mode now
Fusion has joined the chat episode 65.
now do you remember how much more
powerful Vegeta was than Goku and Vegeta
separately well I do and there's no
earthly or Godly way that fusamasu
should have any problem dispensing of
either Goku Vegeta or Tran chunks even
if they teamed up but whatever cool
fight scenes gotta happen I guess and
they don't know how to do that while
making sense doesn't need father-son got
a gun scene that's okay despite it not
making any sense how they're holding
zamasu back but that pales in comparison
to how Goku alone holds his blast back
power scaling matters this is just
confusing and weird episode 66 this is
the big Action episode and it feels like
that in every sense of the word from the
pacing to the tension to the set piece
and even to the sense of desperation
that builds up towards the end I don't
think I even need to go over what
happens in this episode you've all
already seen it it looks visually very
impressive and has some really nice
ideas for techniques too like the final
Kamehameha just a tasteful bit of fan
service with that one but one aspect a
lot of people seem to dislike about this
episode was how they handled the
diffusion of the two main characters
Goku and Vegeta it's revealed in this
episode that there is in fact a time
limit for Mortals wearing these earrings
this is my take on this scene this is
not a red gun a rate con is a a change
to a previously established rule this
forever fusion with the earrings was
once a rule yes but because Vegito
defused in the boom Saga without any
explanation the retcon doesn't happen in
super it happens in The Bu Saga the only
thing super did was offer an explanation
for that diffusion so stop being babies
about it I'm not defending this Arc by
any means but I'm not going to criticize
it over something it didn't do I'm
genuinely trying to be fair here the
fight as I said was fantastic but as
I've explained the two defuse because
tension needs to happen and Trunks hops
in the final moments to make the save I
love how the corruption Arc that zamasu
has gone on has manifested visually in
his appearance the choices he's made
having left his face and body grotesque
and disfigured he screams at trunks both
menacingly and uncomposed it's a great
position his character has ended up in
Against The Virtuous hero of trunks and
I can even make peace with fuse zamasu
being weakened after his battle with
Vegito or with him being emotionally
compromised enough for trunks to make a
difference here sort of but then this
happens
[Music]
so trunks can do the Spirit Bomb with
his sword despite never Having learned
the move it never been foreshadowed or
it even been mentioned a single time
within the entire story within the black
Universe 6 Resurrection F or Battle of
Gods arcs
okay this is so unbelievably dumb like
it looks cool but it is a massive deus
ex machina coming out of thin air to
facilitate an ending the writing staff
or Akira Toriyama didn't plan for it
it's a truly awful ending episode 67 an
arc that started with the best first
episode I've ever seen now ends with the
single worst ending I've ever seen
literally every single character except
for Mayan Trunks from that timeline dice
remember those soldiers Den remember
yajirobi and the other civilians dead
remember those little children that
started cheering for trunks first giving
him the energy he needed to save the
world well they're super dead I'm not
even dead in the traditional Dragon Ball
sense of the word where they effectively
just go to a different part of the
universe forever oh God no they are dead
dead like they don't even nor can they
ever exist anymore and why is this a
problem well because it makes the entire
and I mean entire Arc utterly painfully
and irreversibly pointless so zamasu
becomes the sky because he's Immortal
and that's what Immortals do if they
fuse with Immortal and get slice in half
apparently Goku has the bright idea then
to smash the Xena button and the little
guy literally erase faces the entire
universe so that's fun trunks then goes
on to live with future my and Future
Trunks in a timeline where the events of
black never happened living with
themselves and no one mentions why this
is such a terrific existential nightmare
and the Ark comes to a close everyone is
weirdly happy and Trunks leaves crying
as he looks at Gohan who played
virtually no role in this Arc what's
happening okay uh I've mentioned the
story doesn't make sense numerous times
during this video and I understand that
a lot of people can look past that
because things look cool so why does
something not making sense stop someone
like me from enjoying something well
take this for an example imagine you
have two men fighting on a log floating
on a giant Lake it's just a regular lake
with nothing special about it it's in
the real world both can swim and
suddenly one kicks the other in the
water suddenly the man submerged in
water without warning spontaneously
catches fire and explodes this would be
a bad ending because it breaks the rules
of how we understood that scene should
work a story works the same way if an
ending breaks the established logic and
rules put in place it feels nonsensical
lazy and idiotic an example of a good
piece of Storytelling was seen in
episode 53 it's believable that beerus
and Wiesel would recognize Black's key
from zamasu's fight with Goku as it is
an established part of how powers in the
show work it also stands to reason
zamasu wouldn't be on the defensive
because he would have known knowledge of
the events as he hasn't become evil yet
so that works but this Arc is filled
with a lot of really and I mean really
stupid choices for the story not because
they were choices made by dumb people
far from it toei has shown that they can
write compelling episodes time and again
what is abundantly clear to me looking
at the choices they have made however is
that they are uncompromisingly focused
on one thing Above All Else marketing
they are not concerned about telling a
compelling thought-provoking or
well-written story first and foremost
they're concerned with what will get the
audience's excited via trailer the most
Future Trunks does absolutely nothing in
this except learn all the same lessons
he did in the cell Saga in order to keep
him relevant with the main cast and
competent in the fight scenes he gets
one absurd power boost after another
climaxing in a finish that while
delivered in favor of the right person
and while appropriately visually
striking it has carried out utilizing a
technique with no prior foreshadowing
established history or anything really
it comes out of nowhere because the
writers had nothing established for the
character to carry out his big finish
the original first Super Saiyan
transformation with Goku and Namek
against Frieza worked because it was
foreshadowed the same for Goku
teleporting sell away during the Cell
Games the same for the Spirit Bomb
against Vegeta these were all satisfying
finishes utilizing techniques that had
been clearly established prior to their
use in their respective climaxes and if
you don't believe me that marketing was
the driving force for a lot of these
decisions Vegito the fusion of Goku and
Vegeta is supposed to wear a combination
of clothes Goku and Vegeta were
currently wearing before they threw the
old bling on their ears but they ignore
that in super because that's what
vegito's toy is supposed to look like
and they can change that Goku black and
zamasu's existence didn't make any sense
within the established logic of the show
and I'm saying this now the Canon X
explanation is wrong but to explain why
believe me will require a long
explanation because believe it or not
it's stupidly complicated with so many
moving Parts it's a wonder toei were
able to Bluff their way through using it
though it does explain why so many
people don't notice that it doesn't make
sense in the community it's way too
convoluted to even figure out completely
I fully intend on addressing and
explaining why this particular Canon
explanation is wrong but that will take
an entire video and trust me this will
be a long entirely separate video also
the ending of the arc is I think the
biggest slap in the face Dragon Ball has
ever to this date delivered to its
audience not only are there no
consequences leading on from this Arc
but the means with which they revert
back to the status quo is insultingly
lazy and disrespectful to the
intelligence of the fans that diligently
followed along week after week in
addition to all of this scattered
throughout our various sections of
exposition and info delivered seemingly
without any thought or care put into how
it would affect the established World
Goku has never killed
what trumps can do a Spirit Bomb with
his sword what everyone dies and nothing
matters and I'm sad now what and those
are my thoughts on the Goku black Arc
it's mindless but it is visually fun so
if you turn off your brain I'm sure
there's plenty to enjoy I just happened
to really not like it this time which
finally brings us to the last
of this massive review and in my opinion
the most irritating and interesting I am
of course talking about the universe
survival Arc and Tournament of power
yeah
thank you
all right so this is pretty much the
same situation as the last episode
Dragon Ball super likes to shove a bunch
of random disconnected mini arcs and
Standalone episodes sandwiched in
between its main story points so I'm
going to quickly go over these to get to
the main entree but hey on the bright
side I actually really liked some of
these sort of kind of episode 68. this
episode isn't one of those episodes that
I actually kind of liked in fact I
really didn't like it it centers around
making a wish in the dragon balls are
something Goku wants to Wish King Kai
back and Bulma wants to wish for
something else it's honestly one of the
weaker episodes for me in all of the
series episode 69 this
I think is disliked more than liked by
the vast majority of the fandom but I
actually kind of liked it because it's
just so weird it's like this strange
self-aware but not really fever dream
but also a crossover with Akira
toriyama's two most successful manga
properties also Goku gets a slick new
hairstyle for like three seconds but
yeah episode 70. this episode has the
spirit of one of the most enjoyable
Filler episodes in the original run of
Dragon Ball for those of you out there
that do not know what I'm talking about
in Dragon Ball Z there was an episode
most fans affection labeled as the
driving episode why you ask because it
was an episode about uh go driving what
can I say the Dragon Ball Community
we're a simple people point is the
episode despite not having anything to
do with the main story it didn't
contradict pre-established mechanics or
attempt to reintroduce anything
meaningful it was just a great Slice of
Life opportunity for real fun character
interactions and comedy this episode in
Dragon Ball super now affectionately
labeled the baseball episode because
they played baseball nailed it is just
like its companion in the original anime
it's just a whole mess of fun with loads
of wonderful interactions and a
surprisingly touching ending for Yamcha
if you haven't seen it I highly
recommend it it's one of my favorites
episodes 71 and 72. okay so these two
episodes are the first of three count
them three entirely unrelated separate
mini arcs as is the nature of these
pre-arc Filler episodes anyways these
first two episodes and their story are
serviceable my interest was held fairly
well throughout and unlike the Goku
black Arc it had an ending that while
not special doesn't make me want to claw
my eyes out with the rusty Fork
#progress essentially the first episode
follows a Goku that is consistently
looking behind his back paranoid that
he's being followed leading to all sorts
of hijacks but the climax of the first
episode is a shocker it turns out hit
has been given his name to assassinate
and does just that sending a blow to
Goku's chest stopping his heart
thankfully though Goku has a contingency
plan to bring him back to life which
actually works shockingly in the second
episode leading to their fight to
continue with the final episode's
conclusion revealing that Goku put the
hit out on himself I actually am
disappointed I didn't see that coming
episode 73 and 74 a modern day
Masterpiece of Dragon Ball storytelling
acting as the debut for Dragon Ball's
new leading man Barry Khan the victim of
success he falls into a Chasm of his own
Creation in the wake of a parasitic
outbreak again this is Barry
demonstrating his range as a performer
and a character he becomes the tragic
hero as the story comes to a close and
the antagonist Gohan wins the day this
two-part Shakespearean tragedy tells the
incredibly yet devastating tale of
hubris betrayal and deceit center around
Dragon Ball's newest and most physically
attractive new leading man Barry Khan
it's two out of 10 Bad episode episode
75 and 76 off the back of an incredibly
boring collection of episodes covering a
weird parasitic relationship and I know
I'm not over the loss of Barry as the
focus character he did nothing wrong
except light cheats stealing possibly
spot something sinister but who Among Us
is perfect
[Applause]
mini Arc is the best of the three and is
honestly one of two on a number of
this re-watch and it very well might
contain some of my favorite character
scenes to come out of Dragon Ball super
and to think it all centers around
Krillin it starts off as Goku instigates
a reunion between Krillin himself and
master roshi as they attempt to learn
more from The Hermit however Brewing
beneath the surface of Krillin is a
palpable insecurity that if you know the
character and aren't familiar with him
has always been there really
complimented by some understated music
and gorgeous storyboarding it really
drives home how isolated and small
Krillin feels no pun intended especially
when next to Goku coming to a head
during a trip planned by Master roshi
built to expose them to their greatest
enemies of their past Krillin freezes
and Goku takes action noticing this Goku
tries to reassure him leading to Krillin
exclaiming I'm not like you Goku I'm
scared that was a genuinely great line
as I got the feeling that while he said
this he wishes he was more like Goku but
this isn't the first time that he's
thought of this that it's something he
recognized about himself and he knew
that no matter what he's never going to
be Goku if you haven't seen it I highly
recommend it it's more of lifting
towards the end which is nice but those
dramatic scenes towards the beginning
are my favorite by far great mini Arc
and that concludes the pre-universe
survival Arc filler material not all bad
in fact some of them were great so
without further Ado let's dive into the
main stuff episode 77 finally we are
starting the ark and what I'll be
discussing today can be divided up into
three sections number one the setup
number two the preliminary tournament
and matches that come with that nonsense
and number three the recruitment Arc
itself the episode comes with some new
visual updates and a brand new OP that
is hopping I'm sorry I'm a big fan of
the opaque the entire visual in art
style is practically the exact same with
some minor changes that make a
significant difference I think all done
in post two to desaturate the colors and
to thicken up the lines overall a decent
Improvement I think in addition to these
new visuals in the episode we get a ton
of setup in short some time has passed
since the last dark that made me want to
do bad things to my eyes and it Goku is
going about his farming stopping Bandits
and goes to meet Weiss and beerus for
training yet again all before
remembering zetto wanted to hold hold a
tournament Goku then takes it upon
himself to remind the little ticking
time bombs yes no there's two one from
the yated Future Trunks universe that
makes me sad to think about yet that
Universe well that Universal Zeno now
bumps with this universe Zeno and Goku's
meeting with them leads these little
sociopaths to announce the torment of
power requiring 10 representatives from
each Universe to participate episode 78
in the space of one episode Goku has put
the entire Multiverse at risk to
effectively scratch an itch no I won't
go as far as to suggest that Goku knew
that this massive threat would happen in
fact I'm certain he believes Zeno was
nothing to be afraid of as every
encounter he's had with the little guy
up until now was pleasant
sort of but even in that case I'm sure
he didn't directly blame Zeno as he was
reacting to something that could only be
addressed that way or whatever point
being I don't think it's as simple as
saying Goku put the universe in danger
now I can easily see the argument for it
and in some ways I agree with it just
not very strongly but anyway that's
essentially the gist of this episode The
Grand priest a character that looks
feels and is sometimes shot in his Super
Evil but totally isn't evil sort of way
comes and reveals the stakes of the
tournament of power touting that the
universe is with the worst levels would
participate in an elimination Battle
Royal style match with the last Universe
left standing earning a wish on the
Super Dragon Balls oh and they will die
that last part is important I actually
really liked this episode as it does two
things really well it gives us a
long-term goal being the tournament of
power and its ending as well as a
short-term goal to look forward to right
away this is tremendous for story pacing
and takes the form of a preliminary
contest between Universe 7 which happens
to be the second worst ranked Universe
by some Metric against the single worst
ranked universe the ninth one we haven't
seen yet Goku is instructed by beerus to
take responsibility for finding two
other fighters who make up the numbers
for the preliminary Zeno Expo which he
does in Gohan and Majin Buu who really
hasn't done anything in super yet except
eat pudding not share lose to beerus and
sleep at really inopportune times also I
love how Gohan reacts to Goku's news
like any sane person would stressing and
looking at Goku to take accountability
it's at this point that they decide
keeping the consequences of the
tournament is Best Kept to themselves
for some reason I don't know it's not
like the Gang has a history of causing
Mass hysteria they arrive at the grounds
for the mini Face-Off against the
representatives from Universe 9 three
wolf-like Warriors known as the trio de
donger take the Stage episode 79 first
up is Majin Buu vs basil from the ninth
universe and if I'm being honest this
fight is fun as all hell it's by no
means super dramatic or aesthetical but
it's certainly not boring either there's
some great character moments with Majin
Buu and the action is complemented
terrifically by the stretching and fluid
animation style it's a refresh rushing
episodes centered around Majin Buu it
took 79 episodes to get here but they
finally did something with them episode
80. next up Gohan vs lavender Gohan in
this episode I was curious to see what
they would actually do with it pitting
him up against the crafting underhanded
lavender seemed to me like the perfect
compliment to Gohan's good boy demeanor
and it was in a lot of ways both from an
aesthetic and story perspective right
from the get-go lavender removes the use
of Gohan's Vision using his unique
abilities there's honestly some great
action here and it's benefited immensely
by how simple the story of the battle
was Gohan effectively has to use his
intelligence and composure to find
lavender he has to feel his presence and
has to wait for the sounds he makes it's
a very enjoyable and easy watch that
ultimately ends in a draw episode 81
Goku vs Bergamo because of the way the
last two matches have ended there isn't
really any pressure on Goku as they
can't really lose the match at this
point Majin Buu won in Gohan Drew so
thinking of it like that Universe 7 is
very much in the driver's seat here and
that's not to say it's a bad thing or
that Goku should always be on the the
back foot and he shouldn't but there's
no tension in this fight as Goku
proceeds to dominate the Intrigue in the
prior matchups came from us not knowing
how Majin Buu would battle against as we
haven't really seen much from him and in
the case of Gohan it was the interesting
story he told in there with lavender but
also again us not knowing how capable he
would be against the universe 9 fighter
but in the case of Goku we know he
should be totally fine and he totally is
so we are effectively just waiting for
him to win it's not even played out in a
way that lets us sit back and watch as
Bergamo understands what he's gotten
himself into either with Goku so I'm not
really sure where the interest and entry
for this fight was supposed to come from
and part of me feels like toy animation
knew this because toppo has a match with
Goku set up right afterwards however all
in all Goku's final match up against the
final member of the ninth Universe was
the weakest of the three I think quite
obviously episode 82 while all the
prelim matches have been happening the
Supreme Kai of the 11th universe who is
coincidentally or perhaps appropriately
called Kai convinces the Thanos to allow
his bodyguard to fight Goku is revealed
to be a Dr Robotnik looking sort of
character taking the stage to face off
against Goku somewhat interestingly this
guy has a unique moveset implementing a
lot of techniques in the forms of
various locks that dislocate Goku's
shoulder but naturally Goku ignores the
fact that this would render anyone's arm
completely useless while dislocated and
Yeats his way out of there before
showing toppo some of his big girthy
Power Super Saiyan blue Kaioken times
whatever I don't know but we can't see
any more of that fight because we gotta
save it for the tournament of power next
episode episode 83 so this is the
beginning of the recruitment mini Arc
within which is the greater Universe
survival Arc yeah I know she A thick one
Goku and KO travel back to capsicorp to
outline a plan for Gathering the
necessary Fighters monaka is of course
naturally at the top of Goku's list but
is quickly shot down by Barris leading
to Goku and Gohan agreeing that
themselves Vegeta Piccolo Majin Buu
Krillin Android 18 and her brother and
master roshi for some inexplicable
reason are the individuals that should
make up the first nine leaving one space
free so first things first gotta go ask
Vegeta who is having something of a
nervous breakdown with Bulma just being
super pregnant get it well Vegeta can
focus on anything while his daughter is
about to be born so whis Magic's the
baby out of Bulma and they end up
calling the kid bulla it's a cute
episode and now Vegeta is on board
episode 84. alrighty so right off the
bat I really enjoy the idea of
revisiting old relationships for the
sake of recruitment in this story in
this act specifically too as we are
journeying to a tournament of power and
we need to feel the best team we can
whether or not they have been an active
part of the story doesn't really much
matter at this point in a convenient
albeit unintentional way the nature of
the recruitment feels appropriately
desperate and slap Dash which honestly
Works in a lot of ways for me and was
the tone I assume they're going for
additionally this episode is one of my
favorites from a visual and
choreographic perspective going on Goku
venture to recruit Krillin in 18 for the
tournament leading to Gohan challenging
Krillin to Aspire just testing his power
which I adore because Krillin wins with
tactics rather than raw power I'm all
about that nonsense in this match
Krillin demonstrates a new technique
he's developed it's like a super solar
flare or taiocan or whatever your
persuasion is Goku seeing this gets
excited and so a contest between Goku
and the Krill doc himself is set up atop
a roof descending and choreography for
both of these fights I enjoyed but more
so the Goku fight patoshi higushide an
incredible action animator demonstrates
some of his fantastically imaginative
battle choreography that you really just
gotta check out to fully appreciate for
yourself but then this happens Goku
Super Saiyan blue Kamehameha vs Krillin
this is sort of silly sure I mean it
does have the built-in excuse that Goku
is holding back but I mean how much is
he holding back like all of this it's
like what's the point of him being blue
then just testing his resolve 18 gets
involved leading to herself and Krillin
Jordan and reminding Goku that this is a
free-for-all not a one-on-one contest
episode 85. this is the episode where we
finally get more than one story running
in tandem with the main plot Gohan and
Goku decide to go their separate ways
Gohan to train with and recruit pickles
and Goku to head over to dende so that
he can find Android 17 location on his
way to 10 days Goku discovers Majin Buu
or what's left of him after his sudden
and dramatic weight loss transformation
apparently he got all sight after the
Expo and decided to get into the best
shape he could thankfully he's a magical
creature that has the excuse of using
magic to lose weight otherwise I'd be
wincing again but yeah looking good and
their little tussle wasn't bad either
Goku then finds his way up to 10 days
also in this episode is some
interactions between Gohan and Piccolo
which I will have more to talk about on
at a later point in this video we got
some glimpses into the other Kaizen
Destroyer gods of their universes
discussing strats but it all boils down
to nothing Champa however does tell
Kaaba to recruit more Saiyans so that's
neat this is also the first time we get
to see jiren the strongest fighter from
universe 11.
cool episode 86 this is one of the
prettiest episodes in all of Dragon Ball
super the use of color outstanding
storyboarding terrific background art
which doesn't get enough praise and some
brilliant animation by now kitate to put
the cherry on the top it's a gorgeous
episode and it all centers around Goku's
recruiting of Android 17 who has started
a family after the Cell Games and
settled down as a park ranger of sorts
protecting endangered animals on this
island we get a nice fight between the
two albeit and unrealistic one I think
and we also get a small mention of Ube
too I'm glad they did this great episode
episode 87 this is part two to the last
episode and it's really really weird and
not really weird in a good way either
let me explain while the last episode
felt like Dragon Ball this one sort of
felt more like an episode of Captain
Planet and I didn't even see that show
way before my time so these space
posters show up because something has to
convince 17 to fight in the tournament
of power so why not space poachers
anyway they steal this rare cow or
something forcing Goku and 17 to pursue
the baddies they foil their evil plans
and saved the super rare cow all as well
as 17 agrees to fight the tournament to
power on the condition someone will
protect his Island while he's away and
so Goku puts Goten and Trunks to protect
the cow and stuff episode 88 and we come
to the Gohan episode well technically
it's the Gohan and Piccolo episode but
let's be real here toei doesn't give a
rats behind about Piccolo now so I
digress this is the Gohan episode and a
lot of people will point to this as an
important moment when it comes to the
Revival or Resurgence of Gohan's
character and it is but but not really
let me explain my point of view here
when Gohan is chosen by Goku to be a
participant in his little Skirmish with
the ninth Universe he was very much in
civilian mode we've seen him start
training again thanks to episode 30
which at the very least showed a marked
improvement to the state he was in in
the resurrection effort but let's not
speak of that at this point point is
Gohan has sort of been training
semi-consistently but when this episode
begins Piccolo remarks and I quote so
this is your current level implying
either Gohan hasn't been consistently
training with Piccolo if at all and that
this was Piccolo confirming to himself
what Gohan's current output was capable
of and he wasn't impressed then we get
this interaction between Piccolo and
Goku about Gohan Goku says that Gohan is
out of practice further reinforcing the
notion that Gohan hasn't been training
much if at all since that one time we
saw him train earlier in the series
Piccolo agrees to join the tournament of
power and also agrees to bring Gohan
back up to speed but let's not let the
large number of episodes that have
elapsed since the tournament was
announced distract us from the reality
of the situation from the moment Grand
priest announces the tournament of power
they have a little over 40 hours to fuel
the team and ready themselves and by the
time Gohan and Piccolo have this
interaction in episode 88 half of that
time has already passed which brings me
to my central argument as to why I don't
like this for Gohan while him being
involved in this is nice the cleanup for
his character in this Arc is the
literary equivalent of sweeping dust
under the rug and they even try to hack
him back to his time as a kid training
under Piccolo with plenty of visual
callbacks look it's a dinosaur and
they're eating it like steak but the
difference is that the young Gohan had a
year to prepare himself for the same
Invasion even then it wasn't enough but
that was what it looked like to treat an
important character with care and
respect and let me tell you even if it's
trying to tell us that this is all it
takes to reawaken Gohan's power in super
it's not in the slightest bit earned to
me and doesn't do anything except
devalue the power he once had one
episode might be what Dragon Ball super
is saying it takes to get back to this
point but in reality it doesn't begin to
scratch the surface if they were really
concerned about bringing Gohan back into
the fold and they'd have given him a
build up gradually but they didn't
because to them Gohan isn't worth that
right now again I'm not saying you can't
like this episode hell if you're a fan
of the character I get it you can like
it it's great but wouldn't you want
something more substantial over
something rushed and slap dash for the
sake of plot something that's for the
character and not for the character to
serve an end point personally I would
anyway that's my main takeaway from this
episode along with her first glimpse of
universe 6's additional Saiyans episode
89
episode we get a whole bunch of stuff
it's
Gonna Be by Queen the episode kicks off
with ten shinhan in his dojo which is
cool for his character to have done for
himself it suits him too considering his
background but the episode primarily
acts as a mini episode centered around
this girl with the unfortunate reality
of being named urine roshi acts like a
weirdo and then Goku arrives okay look
essentially this episode acts as a way
for Goku to recruit Master roshi and
even though this is considered the
tension on episode he barely plays a
role in it though he does get recruited
by Goku so that's something in essence
jiren is an underhanded person who winds
up causing Mischief that gets rectified
by the end the important takeaway here
is that Master roshi and Tin shinhan are
in the tournament now episode 90. this
episode is one of those really
well-boarded episodes where we get very
interesting choreography backgrounds
color and artwork it's a very pretty
episode but I wish the story got more
care than it actually did in the end the
episode itself hinges on this
confrontation between Goku and his son
Gohan who has been training super duper
hard for a super long time like at least
a day and essentially he wants to prove
to himself that he is enough to stand
and fight with his father in the
tournament he wants to test his
abilities which honestly is cool but
again he's been taking fighting
seriously for like a little over a day
now when you think about it like that
it's hard to take this scene as
seriously as super wants us to take it
right now or at least that's how I felt
when I watched it regardless if I was to
assume that much much more went into
building to this moment the episode
works perfectly fine which means to me
there's nothing wrong with the episode
itself in isolation just its build up
Gohan and Piccolo mozion upped attention
Hanan Goku challenging them to a 2v2
match ultimately leading to Gohan
pushing things super far to Manning that
his father take it as seriously as he
can which he does well sort of I mean he
doesn't go all out like Kaioken times 20
or whatever that nonsense is but he does
turn on the Jets enough for Gohan to
push his limits ending in a nice
father-son moment between the two
characters it's genuinely really nice to
see that and if I haven't stressed it
enough already this episode is
stunningly beautiful with maybe my
favorite shot in the entire series and
episode 91 at this point in the show all
recruitment has been completed for
Universe 7. Goku is training in the
gravity chamber with whis Vegeta's
screaming in the hyperbolic Time Chamber
roshi is even trying to temper his
desires and so on through the view of
the zenos we get to see other universes
assembling their Fighters too Universe 9
is having a lot of trouble finding
anyone to field their team outside of
the trio Universe 6 sees a Down and Out
Frost feeling the effects of his
reputation being ruined after the
tournament in season three as he is
recruited by hit for their team the
episode effectively hops from Universe
to Universe showing their key players
but the main takeaway from this episode
is one of the most irritating things to
come out of this Arc Majin Buu is asleep
again episode 92 I hate and I mean hey
the excuse Majin Buu has to be taken out
of the tournament but if it means we get
someone better it's at least going to
cushion the blow for me so Goku goes to
Mr Satan's and completely fails of
trying to wake up Majin Buu no surprise
there give me something good toei once
he gets back to the team Piccolo has
revealed the truth about the tournament
and its consequences to everyone causing
them to feel understandably betrayed
after learning that they were lied to
Goku apologizes despite it really being
Gohan's idea and everyone forgives him
they're all in this together to The
Bitter End more talking happens and then
Goku is inspired to seek out a
replacement someone far better than
Majin Buu but far far worse at the same
time
freezing
[Music]
this episode also covers some more
Antics from Universe 6. Kaaba tries to
teach another Saiyan recruit from his
home planet her name is cauliflower and
he's trying to help her to turn Super
Saiyan in a really really really weird
way like he describes it as a tingly
feeling in the back okay dude like
please just stop making the legendary
rage form of your people so incredibly
lame anyway she learns to transform
almost immediately thrilling I know you
think if it was that easy so I'm saying
out of their entire population or even
history would have stumbled upon the
form eventually I don't know stupid
episode 93 so everyone questions or
straight up refuses to involve someone
like Frieza but Goku comes up with the
great idea of utilizing fortune teller
Baba's 24-hour return policy which would
give Frieza enough time to participate
but not Grant him life again it's a good
plan if you ask me meanwhile in Universe
6 the Saiyans continue to prepare with
Khalifa getting more and more Adept with
her new form another Saiyan by the name
of kale a Meek on assuming shy female
Saiyan tries to learn the form too but
fails time and again leading to a
frustration crawling beneath the surface
turning her into the green-haired
Legendary Super Saiyan whatever I don't
really know what to do with this
information I suppose she's a wild card
it's not uninteresting I just don't
really care about the character yet we
get more glimpses of other Universe
preparing for the tournament while
Universe 4's Destroyer katila is
informed of universe 7's plan to revive
Frieza and thus begins his plan to
sabotage the initiative but who cares
about that because right now we get my
favorite scene maybe in all of the show
I adore this interaction between Goku
and Frieza it's tense there's this
feeling in the air that something could
go wrong at any moment with these two
characters vying for the upper hand in
this deal the use of color is brilliant
and the cherry blossoms falling from the
heavens representing rebirth are
appropriately Sinister and that's not
even mentioning masconazawa's
performance here as Goku this is Goku at
his best to me and he's appropriately
serious and himself more importantly in
this scene no stupid super Goku here
folks the deal however is made Frieza
will fight for Universe 7 but only on
the condition that if they win he will
get his life back appropriately
targeting Goku's weak point I love it
episode 94 to be perfectly honest this
Arc of the show has been significantly
better than a lot of what I'd seen
before the Goku black Arc was
entertaining very entertaining and I did
enjoy it while it was on the air but as
a complete story it left a lot to be
desired but this Arc it's so simple that
it's much easier to make sense of and
therefore even when things like Majin
Buu happen stuff like Frieza can
completely reinvent the atmosphere
surrounding an upcoming event like the
tournament of power and if that wasn't
all this episode had one of my absolute
favorite moments in all of Dragon Ball
not just super all of Dragon Ball and no
I'm not talking about Frieza punching
Goku in the god well yes that was a
great moment it's not what I'm talking
about so the episode kicks off as katila
is storing more doo-doo with the ninth
universe's God of destruction Sidra
basically informing him about Frieza and
inspiring him to work together with him
to assign assassins to take Frieza out
before he can take part aside from that
Goku lets everyone back at bulma's Place
know that he needs to go pick up Frieza
from Baba and after he leaves 17 and the
rest of the team start to arrive lovely
great now time for my favorite part a
moment I honestly missed the very first
time I saw it but one that really
brought a tear to my eye when I noticed
it so the scene begins as Goku is
waiting patiently outside of Baba's
Palace for Frieza and it looks like he's
just entertaining himself keeping busy
with some sparring and he is but it's
not just simple sparring Goku is
reliving the specific fight he had
against his grandpa Gohan the last time
he saw him strike for strike jump for
jump beat for beat what an absurdly
touching and perfect Easter egg for
those Among Us that would notice
beautiful once that is over Frieza shows
up finally and in a dramatic fashion
with really pretty artwork too the two
share a really fun character moment
before they are ambushed by the
Assassins sent by the other universes
gods of Destruction this is such a fun
situation for these two mortal enemies
to be caught in together Goku knows that
he needs to leave ASAP for the
tournament but Frieza unable to restrain
himself shoots one of them from the sky
without a care in the world guess we're
fighting her way out of here episode 95
and finally we get the most
action-packed episode of this Arc so far
and my God is it great the last three
episodes have shown us Frieza not like
Resurrection F did but at his most
conniving and Sinister this is top tier
Frieza without exaggeration slicing
through the Assassins like butter
sometimes literally and all with a smile
on his face you can tell this is the
most fun he's had in a very long time
and I am here for it one of the minions
was assigned the duty of delivering a
specific special attack and energy blast
given to them by Universe 9's God of
destruction its literal Destroyer energy
and it poses a real threat to both Goku
and Frieza Frieza thinks he gets the
upper hand on the blast but it finally
reaches its Target and connects with
Frieza Frieza is far stronger now than
we ever gave him credit for he can
overcome it and control it we're turning
it to size disposing of its wielder with
ease and then using it on an unprepared
Goku this all feeds into the notion that
Frieza is a complete and unpredictable
wild card in this upcoming tournament
that cannot be trusted using this moment
of reprieve Frieza makes contact with
Universe 9's Destroyer to negotiate
Frieza it's clear is obviously not a man
of his word and at the first chance he
attempts to bargain Elsewhere for a
better deal than Goku offered however
the conversation is cut short by bears
who blows the Blast away from Goku with
ease much to Goku's relief there's
clearly some tension that needs to be
addressed between the two and so they
have a quick scuffle in the moments they
have left before they absolutely need to
leave the fight isn't fantastic or
anything but it's flashy and the artwork
is spectacular supplied by naotoshi
shida it's another wonderful addition to
the series the two land massive shots on
each other before Calling it Quits they
make their way to the team it's time to
travel to the world of void for the
tournament of power man that concludes
the recruitment Arc so what did I think
honestly looking back over the sections
of the show not having to wait week to
week to week for another episode made it
much much more enjoyable this time
around no obviously I still have my
issues I don't really like how the new
Saiyans achieve their powers and I am
massively unimpressed with how they just
write out Majin Buu like that I have no
issue with the staff not wanting any
character to take part mind you but at
least create a decent reason to exclude
them you know maybe they are kidnapped
or maybe they don't want to or maybe
their powers are forbidden or something
my point is anything but falling asleep
is okay especially seeing as this isn't
the first time they've used that excuse
with this specific character the one
minute aspect that made this somewhat
tolerable for me was that the substitute
was a much much more interesting
character to me prior to learning Frieza
was going to take a spot in the universe
7 team I never really cared all that
much for the tournament I mean I was
into to it sort of but when Frieza was
added to the mix it created an entirely
different vibe around the arc on top of
that the episodes of Frieza had in this
section are some of my absolute
favorites from the entire series and
that includes Dragon Ball Z from a
visual perspective I thought that this
Arc was really strong too long got her
the days where Goku looked like a
plastic figure melting under a
magnifying glass now we get a
consistently higher level of model
correctness in addition to some of the
best boarded episodes in this series to
date with the Krillin episode the 17
recruitment episode and the battle
between Goku and Gohan overall I thought
this Arc did really well in establishing
the stakes setting up the tournament and
building Intrigue around the event well
okay almost everything was taken care of
foreign
[Music]
first up quick rundown of the team the
team captain whatever that means is
Gohan after intense training for a day
and a half next Piccolo Krillin tension
on Androids 18 and 17 Master roshi
inexplicably Vegeta after a bunch of
time in the chamber of Goku naturally
and the wild card
Frieza the rules eliminate the other
universes participants by knocking them
off the edge of the Arena oh also
there's no flying you get disqualified
by taking your life or by using
enhancements so no poison for frost if
everyone on the team is eliminated then
the entire universe they represent and
them get erased well that's sufficiently
terrifying oh and also seeing as I have
like 36 episodes to get through today
I've decided to break these bad boys
into groups of three starting with
episodes 96 97 and 98 so let's Dive In
unfortunately during the production of
this Arc the original Japanese voice
actor of Bulma hiromitsuru tragically
passed away the last line she recorded
for the show being everyone good luck
we're counting on you I think it goes
without saying that she will be deeply
missed by millions around the world and
that her impact on all of her lives
cannot be understated the first episode
itself deals with the Prelude to the
tournament during which Goku actually
has a brief interaction with jiren which
effectively sets up Goku's goal for the
entire tournament get to jiren and
battle him in addition to that we also
get jiren's first sentence it's short
and reveals nothing such as the exposure
jiren has received thus far in addition
to this interaction we get a glimpse of
Frieza meeting Frost for the very first
time making a secret Alliance so it's
gonna be interesting to see how that
plays out later on and with those brief
interactions shown to us the tournament
gets underway and the chaos ensues and
that's what I noticed a really weird
decision that's made at the very
beginning of the tournament where almost
every character from Universe 7 that
lasts the longest are the first to act
alone now I can sort of see what they're
trying to go for here the theme of this
Arc is very clearly that of trust and
teamwork and so starting from a position
where they are not working as part of a
team makes sense to build a Story upon
going from not working as a team to then
learning its value but in doing this
you're throwing literally everyone else
who actually does work as part of a team
from the get-go under a bus which sort
of flies in the face of the entire theme
of this Arc and it's not like most of
these guys do well in the tournament as
a result of teamwork for very long
either but I'm getting ahead of myself
here as the tournament commences chaos
ensues half of universe 7 remains in a
tight huddle strategy which honestly is
smart as the other universes do could
out as the fighting ensues throughout
the tournament Goku and Vegeta
eventually are cornered by the ninth
Universe before completely blowing them
away with a series of attacks throughout
the opening minutes of the event making
Universe 9 the first to be eliminated
from the tournament of power and
ultimately erased from existence this
establishes that the rules are 100
serious and the reality of that
situation can be seen on everyone's
faces still participating as they all
take pause episodes 9 99 100 and 101
these are a fun collection of episodes
the first deals with Krillin primarily
as he along with Android 18 confront and
eliminate Majora from Universe 4. it's a
fun little episode climaxing in a
feel-good Krillin moment but quickly
takes a negative turn when he is
blindsided by Frost and sent to the
spectator's bench Krillin is the first
fighter eliminated from Universe 7.
after this cauliflood decides to
confront Goku about wanting to learn how
to turn Super Saiyan blue which Goku
says is way too advanced for her and
that she should instead focus on the
other forms of Super Saiyan Goku in this
moment sort of assumes a mentor type
relationship with cauliflower and the
two end up battling and having a lot of
fun when they are going back and forth
this however seems to really bother her
friend sister pupil who is kale to
cauliflower anyway she begins going
berserk again in this weird green Super
Saiyan form which to be perfectly honest
is almost on par with the original
Broly's motivation at least when it
comes to Stakes I don't like sharing I
don't like crying I swear if the Broly
movie couple years ago didn't recreate
the Broly character from scratch my head
Cannon would be that in order to have
the green hair as a Super Saiyan you
have to be really stupid anyway she
pretty much goes on her Rampage
throughout the arena knocking around
various Fighters eventually Landing
herself in a position where Universal
11's most basic Fighters all start
ganging up on her Goku and cauliflower
forming a temporary alliance between the
three eventually it becomes the case
that Kailyn cauliflower are cornered and
need then to rely on each other's power
leading to kale actually learning how to
control the power temporarily together
the two young Saiyans combined their
attacks in a blast that I swear looks
like an ice cream I had when I was a kid
and in doing so eliminating a bunch of
fighters from the 11th Universe the
episode itself ends proper with Goku
giving the two girls time to recharge
and regain their stamina after their
clash with Universe 11. episodes 102 103
and 104. okay so no time to waste
because Brienne literally everyone's
favorite character makes her grand
entrance and demonstration flanked by
two other magical girl parodies together
in this episode they pretty much end up
trying to transform like a whole mess of
times and don't get me wrong it's a cool
transformation sequence but geez does
this go on and on for the sake of a joke
and saving time and animation Brienne
eventually does get to transform into
her ultimate stage ribrian your favorite
character in mind and as I've said she
is sort of a parody on the magical girl
genre which I actually like and her
design is hilarious too but that charm
is gone soon after with the frequency
with which she makes the same gags over
and over and over although that's less
of a problem with her and more of a
common trait in Dragon Ball in general
however the episode itself continues as
ribrian goes on a rampage around the
arena grossing on Vegeta and knocking
out a bunch of no names 17 meanwhile is
having a great fight with one of the
other magical girl fighters called
kakunsa the episode itself has some
really imaginative fight sequences and
some great artwork ending in 17
eliminating both her and vikal from
Universe 2. later we see Gohan
eliminating China's president leading to
both he and Piccolo fighting the last
two members of universe 10. ultimately
winning that exchange and seating the
Fate of that Universe Gohan looks at the
last Fighter's locket with a picture of
his family as the fighters and deities
vanished Before Their Eyes Gohan Mourns
as the 10th universe is eliminated and
erased from existence the stakes are
indeed high with Universe 10 now done
for we then switch gears to another
battle that is getting underway between
hit and universe 11's dyspo he's joined
by his Universe 11 teammate kunchi
leading Goku to offer hits some backup
utilizing his Super Saiyan God form for
the first time since season 1 to match
dyspo speed together they eliminate
kunchi but dyspo does manage to retreat
it's actually a fun little episode and
it's always refreshing to see something
like Super Saiyan God which up until
this point had been criminally underused
episode 105 106 and 107. okay so these
episodes are really a mixed bag what is
good one is really bad and another is
actually really good so we're batting
two for three here episode 105 pretty
much focuses on and covers Master roji's
fight with a duck and it's actually
really touching more specifically this
episode deals with Master Roshi's
thoughts on his life his father
philosophy and what he'll be leaving
behind if he does go here and now while
charging what seems to be one last
Kamehameha from the originator of the
technique we receive dialogue that
effectively captures my love for an
entire era of Dragon Ball in just a few
short lines and it was most definitely
enough to squeeze a few tears for me too
after this roshi falls lifelessly to the
floor spurring Goku on to completely
forget about the fight he's having and
engaging in right now to rush to his
side Goku somehow miraculously brings
roshi back to life through some unknown
power and once the old guy starts to
stir Goku quickly reverts back to being
his innocent self the same way he was in
early Dragon Ball it's a tender moment
and honestly it worked really
effectively for me the next episode
however is one that primarily deals with
a sniper and 10 shinon who barely
manages to eliminate a single person Bad
episode it's okay look it's really not
my thing personally it really lacked any
sense of suspense and honestly felt out
of place amidst the rest of this
tournament so moving on episode 107 has
some really strong storyboarding when I
first saw Frost receiving instruction
from Champa at his Palace on what his
plan of action should be for it to
subtly Fade Into the tournament arena in
a flash of lightning I knew I was in for
a treat here it was seamless and
Brilliant also within this episode this
weird Blue Water fighter majikayo causes
dyspo trouble until Jared finally does
something and eliminates the potentially
dangerous fighter with little effort so
that's pretty cool anyways Frost begins
fighting Master roshi who is struggling
against him because of course he is but
get this Frost is suddenly put on the
back foot by roshi which is at least to
me hilariously unrealistic but at least
it's not for long and without prior
warning roshi bursts out the mafaba
technique on Frost I keep getting
surprised by that thing however roshi is
very much at his limit and doesn't
possess enough strength to execute the
move flawlessly resulting in Frost's
Escape completely taken aback by this
the universe 6 fighter quickly
formulates a cunning clan that involves
getting the attention of Vegeta firing
an attack towards the same who blocks it
with ease investigating the situation
Vegeta rushes in only to be suddenly
attacked by an old rival negative who's
defending Frost now armed with earplugs
but get it now has no obvious weakness
in an effort to help Vegeta Master roshi
uses the mafaba once again but this time
Frost redirects it and uses it on Vegeta
instead all this time he was waiting for
this opportunity seating Vegeta away in
a vial Frost seems to have gotten his
revenge on the Saiyan prince turning his
attention once again back to roshi Frost
releases a barrage of blasts during
which roshi manages to throw a tiny
undetectable blast that meets his Mark
breaking the vile unleashing Vegeta and
his wrath exploding forth from the
prison in a blue flash of light after
this Frost like the smoke bombs away
like a 60s cartoon villain and Vegeta
knocks megetta out of the ring much like
he did the last time Vegeta respects
roshi after this but advises him to take
stock of the situation and to eliminate
himself now before something terrible
happens episode 108 109 and and 110 the
special in episode 108 the alliance
freezer made with frost at the
tournament's beginning rears its ugly
hit go on his scene struggling with the
yard drive from the second Universe when
Frieza
comes in and takes control of the
situation easily as Gohan's backup but
then Frost joins The Fray changing the
dynamic entirely Frieza and he seem to
have come to some sort of understanding
which ultimately leads to Frieza needing
to fight Gohan to prove his loyalty to
frost Frieza plays along and transforms
getting what seems to be the upper hand
on Gohan in essence portraying his own
Universe eventually knocking Gohan to
the side with a brief break from the
action Frieza talks to frost unloading
advice unto him as if he wore his mentor
figure the final piece of advice that he
unloads onto him though not to trust
anyone knocking him out of the ring much
to Frost's surprise he had been pulling
his punches this entire time with Gohan
who had also been in on this charade but
who cares about that because now we've
got the real meat and potatoes and I'm
not saying that because I'm from Ireland
I'm saying that because this is when the
action gets turned up to 11. you see
episodes 109 and 110 are the
installments that made up the hour-long
TV special that aired together when
broadcast in Japan it covers the end of
Goku's battle with ribrian which is
really well animated and the first fight
Goku has with jiren throughout the
series jiren has barely been seen to
move but this is where Goku forces jiren
to move like literally the dude won't
move unless Goku makes him it's a really
fun scene that escalates very quickly
from the get-go and there's tension
because we want to know how Goku matches
up to this wall that jiren poses cycling
through his base form Super Saiyan 1 and
2 Super Saiyan God which actually
butches his head a smidge Super Saiyan
blue and even Super Saiyan blue Kaioken
times 20 without any success unless you
consider making him move a success in
which case got him their fight in this
Kaioken variation of the Super Saiyan
blue form is my favorite in this
exchange Goku being flunked The Arena
floor only to explode back into jiren's
face it's pretty great to see there's
also a gorgeous tracking shot of the two
as they fight around the arena passing
all the other Fighters give me a great
sense of scale to the actual occasion
things however become dire as Goku
exhausts pretty much every technique and
option at his disposal well all except
one the Spirit Bomb which happens to
have my favorite accompanying track of
the entire series and that's only the
first half yeah you heard me right this
is only the first half and that first
half ends as jiren forces the Spirit
Bomb back onto Goku who seemingly gets
destroyed in the explosion it's honestly
a crazy sight to behold as the second
half begins everyone is left in awe
after what's transpired when suddenly
[Music]
Goku erupts from the floor presenting to
us the best transformation sequence in
this series not Super Saiyan God or
blooper Saiyan Ultra Instinct has been
hinted at since episode 5 when Goku's
body acted without him against beerus
this is what I call a transformation
that has been built upon and given the
correct occasion and man is the fight
that follows impressive we see Goku
dodged during the attacks with little
difficulty and the action supplied by
toei's finest is spectacular in this one
special we get Rio onoshie yuya
Takahashi nauket and even some notoshi
shida covering the end of the fight as
Goku charges with one final attack
towards jiren before unfortunately
running out of juice at the last moment
before being cast aside with ease by the
Monstrous Universe 11 Warrior the ending
of the episode also is a brilliant
callback role reversal with Frieza
offering up his energy to Goku very
reminiscent of what Goku did for him
unnamik episode 111 112 and 113. so this
episode pretty much covers the after
math of Goku's fight with jiren Goku
himself is entirely spent and needs to
recuperate his energy levels again with
a nice rest while this is all
transpiring it directs his attention
towards jiren as the two begin battling
in doing so hit breaks out a ton of
interesting unpredictable moves against
jiren but none of them seem to work or
have that much of an effect at all
though I must say it is fun to watch the
two of them discover the depths of each
other's abilities first hand it's also
nice to get longer stretches where we
are exposed to jiren more eventually hit
manages to restrain jiren in another
dimension or something with this new
technique he's been developing but even
that isn't enough and with a dominating
attack jiren eliminates hit in just two
episodes jiren has destroyed two of the
strongest contestants of the tournament
and yet we still know very little about
jiren's personality next up is pretty
much for all intents and purposes a
setup episode Piccolo and Gohan start
fighting the universe 6 namekians Kama
becomes Super Saiyan 2 after being saved
and given a pep talk by Vegeta a drained
Goku has trouble with some robots but
Kali flying kale removed them from the
equation essentially this episode is all
about Universe 6 and universe 7's
relationship oh and uh Frieza eliminates
Kaaba too and to be perfectly honest I'm
very disappointed with what little they
did with kava's character
moving on episode 113 is pretty much all
about the fight between Goku and the
remaining Universe 6 Saiyans really
since hit was their leader it has since
been eliminated Khalifa wants to learn
how to turn Super Saiyan 3 to take
charge of her situation for her universe
and so Goku begins fighting her I
actually really enjoyed this interaction
since Goku is redlining when it comes to
energy levels he's forced to rely on his
martial arts knowledge while it is base
form as he regains his stamina slowly he
worked his way back up through the Super
Saiyan forms as kale rejoins the party
and as soon as their teamwork starts to
get the better of Goku he bursts in
Super Saiyan 3 easily overpowering them
before reverting back to Super Saiyan 2.
he still doesn't have enough stamina to
show them everything he's capable of
just yet kale on the other hand who now
seems to be in control of her
green-haired Super Saiyan form tries to
push herself farther into the depths of
her power however in doing so she loses
herself once again ending the episode oh
and by the way ever since hit was
eliminated jiren's been sleeping oh I I
mean meditating episode 114 115 and 116.
taking up right from where the previous
left off Kayla's about to go berserk
once again but cauliflower once again
brings her back from the brink and
together they take on Goku now armed
with even more Firepower the fight is
honestly really pretty in places with
Gorgeous artwork from yuyatakahashi and
even some comedic moments with Frieza
and the Power Ranger guy animated by
yuichi karasawa one of the principal
animators from episode 50 that I also
loved so much as the action begins to
ramp up Goku is able to use his God form
to great effect against the two young
Saiyans eventually cornering them and
forcing their hand to use their trump
card Fusion enter
[Music]
her design is honestly my favorite of
these new Saiyans introduced in the
modern generation of Dragon Ball and as
the fight progresses it becomes obvious
that Goku won't stand a chance against
her if he remains in his God form and so
to remain competitive he uses Super
Saiyan blue leading kefla to respond in
kind by turning super saiyan herself
things are ties and a little tough for
Goku in places but clever uses of the
Kaioken technique keep it from losing
too many of the exchanges but that can
only last so long Goku is still feeding
the effects of the prior battles and
eventually is sent flying to the ground
with two well-placed kicks from Kepler
leading to once again a surge of dormant
energy Brewing from deep within Goku
Ultra Instinct has joined the chat let's
hope this timer sticks around long
enough to make a difference the
re-reveal of ultra instinct is once
again getting fantastic treatment in the
series built up to and demonstrated
using appropriate Framing and on model
artwork and honestly what follows is
some of the most fun fight sequences
sporting solid animation and
choreography facilitating the single
best finish to any Dragon Ball fight I
have ever seen ever ever in my life I
mean it I cannot begin to describe how
much I love that Kamehameha grind that
would make Tony Hawk proud performed by
Goku when he was seemingly out of
options to dodge against kefla's ice
cream attack I quite literally didn't
expect it in the slightest and after
that devastating attack from Goku
Khalifa and kale are eliminated leaving
just two Warriors remaining from their
Universe in the tournament and oh Jared
is awake again neat episodes 117 wood 18
and 119. the next episode covers
rubian's battle with Android 18 and
eventually 17 as they both work together
to eliminate her after assuming a
massive new form the action is honestly
spectacular with cool pieces of
Animation supplied by Rio on a sheet The
Following episode however covers the
remaining two fights from Universe 6.
tunameckians have taken the absorption
ability explained during The nomik Saga
to never before seen Heights the two of
them now represent their entire namekian
race from Universe 6. it's a really cool
and great idea that lends a lot of
credibility to these two utilize a
ritual established ages and ages ago in
the story all the while this is
happening the Androids give Goku some
assistance against the last three
fighters from universe 2. as he is once
again completely drained after his Tango
with the ultra Instinct form however
what follows in this episode is easily
my favorite Gohan fight in the entire
series of Dragon Ball super it
demonstrates his cam demeanor extremely
well as he despite Piccolo losing his
cool finds the resolve to not only pick
up Piccolo's slack but also formulate a
plan of counter-attack he tells Piccolo
that while he takes on the two Universe
6 nemekians he should charge as mcconko
sapo or special beam Cannon depending on
your persuasion Gohan seems to have
bought him enough time but even that
charge isn't enough to pierce the hide
of these Universe 6 Warriors resulting
in a counter-attack leading to Piccolo's
fainting it's at this point we are
greeted with my personal visual
highlight of the episode standing on
either side of Piccolo in a void of
darkness is the spirit of Kami and nail
the Kami Spirit points in front of
Piccolo leading him to come to his
senses as he notices Gohan taking an
attack the same way he did for Gohan
when he was a child during the Saiyan
Saga Gohan still the backbone of the
assault presses the attack on the two
Universe 6 Fighters giving Piccolo ample
time to charge his mcconko sapo as wood
warrior gets dangerously close to
attacking Gohan the young Saiyan refuses
to Flinch having Limitless trust in his
mentor Piccolo makes the save this time
and together they eliminate the last of
universe 6 at the exact same time Goku
and the Androids eliminate Universe 2.
two entire universes have been
eliminated in this episode and what an
episode it was the parallels between
this and the collection of moments
during the Saiyan Saga are not a
coincidence the once terrified child
unable to stick to a plan always
dependent on others to protect him has
become a confident intelligent and
tenacious warrior with boundless trust
in his allies I loved this episode and
to cap it all off there's a very
bittersweet ending as beerus sees his
brother vanished before his eyes
unfortunately what follows this Stellar
show is something of a gimmick episode
following the remaining fighters from
Universe 7 struggling to find eliminate
too hard to see adversaries and while
they do eliminate them both eventually
Piccolo is also eliminated rather
unceremoniously episodes 120 121 and 122
the episode kicks off with Gohan wanting
to give his father and Vegeta a break
from fighting and to take on the robots
from Universe 3 alone as things get a
little more hairy the Androids join in
and eventually Goku and Vegeta do too
it's nice getting to see Gohan act with
some sort of agency instead of him
reacting to situations that befall him
that is a change to Gohan in this Arc
that is most notable to me and one that
I don't see brought up in conversation
nearly enough the next episode begins
and all the robots joined to create an
organic looking creature called anilaza
hey look I don't make up the rules I
just review them but is any laza classed
as a fourth separate fighter or is it
just one big new one and if that's the
case then doesn't it count as the 11th
member of their I don't know anyways
Android 18 is saved by Goku and
eventually sacrifices herself for her
brother so that he can remain in the
tournament 18 is therefore related which
means that Universe 7 is now down to
five Fighters
[Music]
I want to also make a note that all this
time jiren has stood and said almost
nothing there's even been scenes where
his teammates ask him questions and he
still says nothing his meme level
commitment to this silent tough guy
routine is hilarious he slept I mean
meditated in six episodes and since
waking up he has literally stood
silently not fighting mind you not doing
anything for seven episodes thankfully
though episode 122 puts an end to that
trend for jiren as well as doing a
fantastic job in setting up the scene at
the very beginning with only two
universes remaining it's almost framed
like a western close-ups to the gloves
hair and ears of various characters
showing the Stillness and calmness
before the storm of conflict to come is
strikingly effective Universe 11 and
universe 7 are all that remain three
from Universe 11 in jiren dyspo and
toppo and in Universe 7 Goku Frieza
Android 17 Gohan and Vegeta remain and
while the focus is on everyone at the
beginning it most certainly is episode
and yuya Takahashi animates too so
that's always great kicking things off
as the battle between Goku and jiren
quickly becomes a battle that involves
Vegeta demonstrating how he differs as a
fighter to Goku
while all this is going on we see Frieza
vs dyspo as well as toppo vs Gohan at
17. Vegeta begins scuffling with jiren
throwing blow after blow Landing summon
even getting the trash talk a bit in
response however jiren bulldozes through
a gallicon and almost knocks Vegeta out
of bounds however always defiant he once
again stands before the Titan of
universe 11 armed with one last Massive
Attack to test him with a Super Saiyan
blue full powered Final Flash and it is
awesome containing within it a
determination within Vegeta to not Chase
Goku any longer but to blaze his own
path to power and to find his own way of
surpassing it and while that is nice and
while that is a beautiful sentiment it
doesn't work out leading to Vegeta
getting trapped in a Vortex explosion
ball or something by Jaren pointers
Vegeta he's down for the count episodes
123 124 and 125. the battle continues as
Goku fights jiren again in blue but this
time tries to implement strategy either
by setting landmine type energy attacks
or by slicing off the arena beneath them
using the same attack Krillin used
against him in the earlier Arc great
callback coupled with the Instant
Transmission I loved it it looks like
jiren is done for when
[Music]
physics be damned like okay I don't
understand if flying doesn't work then
why does this and this isn't just an
isolated incident either there have been
countless moments during this tournament
where combatants might as well have been
flying he shouldn't survive this anyways
the episode ends with Vegeta rejoining
the fight pushing himself to newer Bluer
Heights I present blooper Saiyan God
blooper saying a blue honestly the
compositing around this new Vegeta form
is too much for me there are so many
light effects Sparkles and CGI fluff
added in post-production I can honestly
barely make out what's happening in
terms of fight choreography Frieza
meanwhile tries to make a deal with
dyspo to play for his team if they
resurrect him with the Super Dragon
Balls dyspo someone intelligently
refuses and Frieza transforms into his
Golden State watching Frieza act as he
would have during The namik Saga is
honestly fantastic and super interesting
he never does more than he needs to and
thinks about every single move he makes
and he's always ready with a terrifying
one letter here and there too that is
while he's in control and dyspo it seems
he can turn the Jets up even more as we
see him pushing Frieza to the edge of
the Arena about to be eliminated Gohan
makes the save leading to a short but
poignant and great interaction between
the two of them Gohan is serious and me
likey the two fight and struggle against
dyspo leading to Gohan needing to
sacrifice himself for dyspo's
elimination both are knocked out as a
result now only toppo and jiren remain
for the 11th universe and for the
seventh Goku Frieza Vegeta and 17 remain
and what follows this episode is
probably one of the strongest episodes
in the tournament I think in terms of
character and it's very fun so Justice
lag Mick Eggman is fighting 17 who's
finding some success with his
inexhaustible energy reserves proving to
be much more of a problem to toppo than
he first anticipated however he does
find his opening and launches a massive
attack towards 17 but at the last moment
right before 17 was about to be
overwhelmed Frieza finds himself in the
right place at the right time unable to
defend himself while holding back 17's
blast Frieza begins trash talking toppo
taunting him and firing blast after
blast at the pride trooper and this is
exactly what Frieza would do it's very
much a cat playing with his food right
now but alas the play must end and end
it most certainly does sandwiching toppo
between both his and 17's attacks
however unluckily for Frieza moments
before he was to knock toppo off the
stage the downed Warrior stands to his
feet once again and assumes the power of
a God of destruction so that's less than
ideal for Frieza in this instance but it
does contain a nice callback to the
moment Frieza control the Destroyer
energy but this time it doesn't work out
though I'm not sure what stopped it from
completely destroying Frieza oh well the
fight with toppo now a God of
destruction fighting 17 resumes leading
to a similar instance where 17 is on the
verge of defeat when
standing atop a rocky Oak crop
reminiscent of his surprise return on
Namek Frieza defiantly blusters at toppo
leading to the near elimination on the
fourth last member of universe 7. Frieza
is now out cold inches from elimination
there's some terrific expressions in
this episode some wonderful animation to
boost and I thoroughly enjoyed it all
episodes 126 127 and 128 the Fight
Continues as toppo gets 17 into a
position of elimination for the third
time when Frieza stops it again MVP of
the tournament don't at me I swear tapa
must think this guy's a cockroach or
something because he is not going away
at all meanwhile the fighting between
jiren Goku and Vegeta gets too close to
the action of Frieza and 17 causing
topple to start fighting Vegeta in
jiren's place in short they fight Vegeta
gets beaten down and is forced to recall
his pass to get a surge of inspiration
to defy the odds and overcome toppo
leading to a recreation of Vegeta's
sacrifice in the buark I do not like
this at all so Vegeta crawls out of the
Creator he sacrificed himself in with a
few scratches and less clothes cool so
Vegeta 17 and Goku all team up against
jiren who brushes them all off without
much difficulty at all throughout this
entire tournament jiren has said nothing
of substance done extremely little and
even spent a large portion of the
tournament sleeping and watching others
fight he has been this emotionless
Terminator type character that literally
acts not as a character but as a plot
device an obstacle for the heroes of
universe 7 to overcome but here we are
five episodes from the finish line and
we get and I'm not kidding here a tragic
cliche Naruto backstory for jiren
when I first saw this I burst out crying
with laughter anyway 17 calls BS getting
on jiren's nerves to such an extent that
he ends up sacrificing himself to give
Goku and Vegeta the best chance to
recover man people really like
sacrificing themselves in this show Goku
Still Remains on the floor but Vegeta
stands defiantly albeit with zero energy
left episode 128 is pretty much
wall-to-wall Vegeta with a little bit of
Goku at the end Vegeta is being beaten
to a pulp by jiren over and over and
over again this was storyboarded and
heavily corrected by the series
character designer tarioshiya Memorial I
mentioned during my battle of God's
review that he worked on the art for
episode 13 as well the artwork similar
to that episode is very on modeled
albeit on the safe side when it comes to
its posing Dragon Ball characters sure
do love to hold their shoulders don't
they regardless Vegeta keeps getting up
again and again to face jiren with the
final time he does coming from his lucky
boot catching him on a piece of random
debris while he's unconscious and that's
the second time his boots and a random
piece of debris have saved him in this
series despite getting up one last time
Vegeta ends up falling off the stage
leaving Goku alone with jiren but not
before giving him all of his remaining
energy Goku tries to make this as much
of a contest as he can using the last of
his and Vegeta's energy but alas it's
still not even remotely enough to test
or push jiren leading to once again a
beaten and weakened Goku on the brink of
losing the entire tournament when
something starts to happen Ultra
Instinct kicks in one more time leading
to the first major or significant strike
jiren has taken and if that face is
anything to go by then we are most
certainly in for a treat episodes 129
130 and 131 these final three chapters
are the Holy Trinity of Dragon Ball
super providing payoff to every
substantial thing they did in this Arc
and show with each episode in my opinion
being better than the last so how did
they go Goku and jiren continue fighting
in the air because who cares of flying
is banned and Goku ends up taking a
massive Blow from jiren who through Goku
whose last two times using the form has
already studied and understood its
movements well enough to successfully
land a shot on this unhittable new form
of Goku's Vegeta gives Goku a pep talk
from the sidelines ordering Goku 2 and I
quote step into the Realms of the Gods
and defeat jiren Kakarot hearing this
Goku rise himself yet again explosions
envelop the arena as yuichikarasawa
another wonderful action animator
provides some great artwork and
animation for the fight to help it feel
as big as it deserves to be however this
desperate flurry doesn't last long and
as fast as it started jiren has Goku
once again pressed down to the ground
and this is when we start to notice
something an energy building a sense of
stability and offense bubbling within
Goku all this time Goku's Ultra Instinct
form had been unrefined an unstable
mainly defensive form however for
someone to truly perfect Ultra instinct
to master it they must also be able to
attack without thinking simultaneously
taking one last deep breath accepting
the power surging within him Goku left
out a massive Roar as what looks like a
galaxy of light surrounds and flows
through him jiren acknowledges and
smiles meeting Goku's power output from
Atop The High Ground respect is now
something jiren has for Goku taking aim
jiren fires the largest attack the
tournament has yet seen towards the
Saiyan that while currently surging with
power is still on a flimsy foothold
inches from defeat the attack is fired
the sound effects blast accompanied by
The Roaring soundtrack when
quiet appearing behind jiren holding in
his hand the Blaster and sent to him
stands Goku shrouded in a phantom white
glow similar to how he appeared behind
him last only this time he lands
consecutive blows while dodging at the
exact same time he has mastered offense
as well as defense this is mastered
Ultra Instinct and what follows this
unveiling is the single biggest fight in
Dragon Ball super without exaggeration
this is the most well animated episode
of Dragon Ball and that includes Dragon
Ball Z with it being the treasure gem it
is online and all it's honestly
wonderful to see a show that started off
as rough as it did rise up to be the
single best demonstration of Animation
in the Dragon Ball episodic series as a
whole with that said there isn't much
Happening Here in terms of writing or
story but there is a nice moment where
Goku straight up says that he isn't a
hero for justice but takes issue when
someone attacks his friends and family
but outside of that it's just
spectacular fight choreography with
every major action effects animator
working on it in some capacity ending on
a cliffhanger with Goku's body rejecting
mastered Ultra instinct to the point of
almost ending him there and then Goku is
done and a swerve I both did and didn't
see coming Frieza is still in play but
also 17 what the final episode is in my
opinion the best episode of the series
by far without question supplying the
most meaningful action of the show
providing the best musical score
inclusions and delivering some of my
absolute favorite lines of not just this
series but the entire Series so let's
check it out this final episode can be
broken up into its Prelude or pre-climax
the climax itself and finally the
conclusion but it's what helps link some
of these parts that I find most
interesting throughout this Arc itself
it has been following the three-act
structure and by all means we are well
within the third act now but this
singular episode adheres to its own
self-contained three-act structure to
perhaps more effectively and closely
than any other episode in this Arc thus
far acting not only as the series and
Arc climaxes but also the climax to this
episode's singular Journey creating a
moment all the more intense and potent
for it one of the most interesting
aspects of this final episode here is
that Goku really isn't the main
character of it he's definitely a major
player but actually acts as more of a
chekhov's gun than the focused character
in this episode in reality in this
episode characters like Frieza and even
jiren are the focus and main characters
of the finish each undergoing their own
hero's journey accepting the call to
action transforming themselves at toning
for what they have done and coming out
the other end different jiren in that he
receives a new outlook on life and
Frieza in that he gets a brand new one
but anyway I don't want to get lost in
the weeds of the hero's journey and this
is a video first and foremost about me
reviewing the series I'm just a really
big fan of this finish and I need you
guys to know first off that there is
much more going on in this episode under
the hood than maybe you might have
realized the episode itself begins as a
weekend jiren has to contend with
Android 17 and Frieza two characters he
thought had been eliminated despite this
he quickly accepts the call to action
and fights them Frieza takes the lead
against the purple brute but what's
interesting is that the entire episode
centers around the main theme of The Arc
and that is trust from the very first
opening line of the episode the exact
theme is mentioned trust by both Frieza
and jiren in their first exchange and
that is most definitely not a
coincidence despite this both he and
Frieza reject the notion of trust and so
begin doing battle relying on their own
strength to get the job done Frieza
begins taunting jiren about how he isn't
the Invincible fighter he thought he
once was and that he isn't intimidated
by him in the slightest this position
frees his character finds himself in is
so interesting to me flirting with the
idea of fighting for good but always
finding a reason to make it about
himself very much in the scenario he is
playing the role of an anti-hero the
same way Vegeta was while fighting the
guinyu force on Namek as Frieza and
jiren were fighting and crashing through
the floor we got an awesome establishing
shot that really demonstrates the scale
of the battle ahead offering us
perspective of where Android 17 is right
now relative to them which becomes
important later Frieza is using every
single weapon he has against jiren
including his intellect it's extremely
compelling stuff the scene even manages
to pull off a swerve two in its short
time with us jiren Rises to the taunt of
Frieza stepping on his tail beginning to
Pummel his body like a punching bag
looking for this reaction however Frieza
uses his telekinesis to crush during
between two Boulders before giving way
to 17's attack having successfully
flanked into the correct position taking
both Frieza and jiren off guard the
Android surrounds himself and jiren with
a strong barrier before creating a
massive explosion around the final
fighter from the 11th universe as the
Smoke Clears jiren falls to his knees
down for the count Frieza walks up to 17
saying you certainly went all out to
stop him didn't you to which 17 responds
by saying even if I failed I knew it'd
be fine if you were still here 17 at
this moment has put all of his trust in
Frieza and hearing this all Frieza can
do is scoff at the idea and
sarcastically quip before moving on to
finish jiren off Frieza at this point
much like jiren still is has no trust in
anyone crushed by the weight of his
defeat at the hands of Goku and now even
Frieza jiren kneels because he has been
mentally defeated but cutting through
the silence topple shouts out to his
Fallen comrade as Frieza teases that his
friend is obnoxious jiren replies
I have no friends toppo continues to
criticize jiren's old way of doing
things training for his pride while
trusting no one tapa rejects all of this
and in the face of certain destruction
puts all of his and universe 11's trust
still in jiren's resolve with this jiren
finally begins to understand what trust
is in himself and in others finding the
mental resolve to pick himself up
exploding with new reserves of energy
this forces Frieza back once standing
alone like he is most comfortable doing
he is forced to stand behind the shield
of an ally that moments ago put his
trust in him and there's tons of
symbolism here Frieza by necessity
needed for his own Survival sake to
stand behind 17's defenses but also
needed to strip himself of his gaudy
golden facade to help The Shield's
Integrity meaning the shield only works
if Frieza trusts 17 with his energy
kicking and screaming at 17 to not tell
him what to do it's obvious that he is
still trying to reject the notion of
relying completely on others this loss
of his golden form also communicates
tension to us the audience for reasons
that are abundantly obvious they are
about to run out of energy The Shield is
buckling and cracking it's about to give
way when
[Music]
this moment this freaking moment on a
fundamental narrative Visual and even
musical level works and I don't use this
word often perfectly and what follows is
my favorite scene in this episode in
this series and maybe even Dragon Ball
Goku by some miracle stands alongside
his teammates one last time formulating
a plan of action 17 is to take care of
backup while he and Frieza deal with
jiren Frieza clearly still doesn't feel
comfortable with this teasing Goku are
you sure you don't want to stay back too
Goku sees through this issue Frieza has
immediate shouting his name reprimanding
his foolish thought process at such a
dire point in the contest confronting
Frieza for the first time about this
side of himself forcing him to see
reason Goku in this moment is showing
the true strength of his character and
it's been like this since the very
beginning of Dragon Ball the flat art
character that shows the truth to those
trapped in the line he says we have all
gone well beyond our limits already if
we don't work together and fight
Universal 7 is going to be erased Goku
then turns his Focus to jiren a changed
fighter partially thanks to him but also
his teammates Goku begins to Marvel at
the level of strength this fighter has
been able to muster and that's when the
most important piece of dialogue cuts
through the air without being provoked
Frieza says
you haven't forgotten about your promise
to resurrect me have you
Goku responds somewhat confused Frieza
I'm asking if you still remember he
screams at Goku so long as you don't
break your promise I'll keep mine you
know that better than anyone don't you
that line was not something Frieza was
expecting but in that one solitary line
it suddenly gives Frieza pause for
thought recontextualizing everything he
understood about what transpired on
nemec Frieza never trusted anyone not
his forces his father and most certainly
not Goku after he begged him to spare
his life and to give him energy what
made that scene dynamic as powerful as
it was wasn't simply the spectacle of
the event but also the story about how
Frieza defeated himself then and there
while begging on that planet not for a
second did Frieza ever consider trusting
anyone that at the first opportunity
he's given he would destroy Goku there
and then and we all know how that played
out now faced with that explanation in
the closing moments of the tournament
Frieza is forced to swallow his pride
except that Goku in this instance might
be onto something and regardless of
whether or not he agrees with him at
this moment he has to trust him he's not
going to make the same mistake he did on
Namek this is the best dialogue Exchange
in all of super no question and for the
first time in the history of this show
both Frieza and Goku fight
unconditionally side by side as a team
for the sake of their home and it is
amazing showcasing a phenomenal
storyboard by The Genius megumi ishitani
who if I'm being honest deserves an
entire video of her own and in addition
to that the bombastic animation supplied
by the incomparable yuya Takahashi
really puts the cherry on top of this
battle and what a battle showcasing
teamwork Maneuvers by both Goku and
Frieza coming in with a flying knee to
jiren's face making the save for Goku at
the beginning getting a boost from Goku
later off the wall and then Goku
returned the favor to Frieza making the
save as the guitar solo slashes through
the action with him fading in and out of
his Super Saiyan form which if I'm being
completely honest is a damn cool Visual
and what caps off the end of tournament
jiren saying this so this is trust
Universe 7's power jiren acknowledges
that trust is a powerful trait to have
and not a weakness this episode man this
episode I adore it the rest of the
episode is tidy up on the details of the
aftermath of the tournament 17 uses the
balls to revive the Fallen universes and
Frieza loses his Halo and gains a life
once again oh also a really fun visual
Easter egg actually happens right after
Frieza gets his life back Frieza teases
whis are you sure about this I don't
intend to stop my evil ways we then cut
to Goku surrounded by Gohan Piccolo
Krillin Vegeta basically everyone who
was around on Namek that's a really nice
touch the gang then goes home both Goku
and Vegeta tease us about the future
while assuming their classic poses from
their Gorge battle and that's Dragon
Ball Super's Tournament of power it's
surprisingly easy and enjoyable to watch
as a binging experience I will however
say that I recall people complaining
about the pacing when it was on the air
week to week which is a justifiable
criticism too I believe there are some
very slow and uneventful episodes and
spots in the ark and if you're not
interested in the character that gets
the screen time that particular week
then you're out of luck and got away
until next week to roll the dice again I
mean there's a reason why I grouped
these by the three instead of reviewing
them individually but in saying that I
love tournament darks and I love them as
much as I do not because of the action
that comes with them but because they
act as a wonderful way to bring
characters and subsequently their
emotional Journeys into conflict with
each other leading to those emotional
Journeys in a lot of ways finding their
resolutions and I think for the most
part the universe survival Arc did that
and was for me the strongest out in the
entire series had by a long long shot
perhaps my biggest issue with The Arc
can be seen with characters like jiren
and even Vegeta who could have had much
more of an impact on the story had they
been handled better and perhaps even the
whole tournament could have been made
slightly more cohesive looking back at
it now but overall re-watching this left
me with honestly more positive than
negatives to talk about and I'm
genuinely happy for that the music in
Parts I believe was used masterfully
well and didn't know there's a little
less well in fact going through this
series again has inspired me to study
Dragon Ball's music more and to be
honest I'm very excited to share with
you all what I found and notice about
this series is music a lot of you have
written to me privately and publicly on
Twitter Instagram and YouTube
reprimanded me for what I have had to
say about the show you love and to that
I say I love the show too I wouldn't be
doing what I'm doing and talking about
this show Dragon Ball if I didn't love
it I hope you guys enjoyed this trip
down memory lane and I will see you all
next week in the next video thank you so
much for watching
foreign
[Music]